Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen Tim.
Ey, das ist ja großartig. Ähm wir werden äh die Medien aber zur Rechenschaft ziehen, dass sie behaupten, dass es viel weniger werden und äh wir haben aber natürlich vor sie nie anzulügen.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer zweihundertsieben. Euer alternatives Faktenmagazin.
Ich muss sagen, diese Alternativen, diese neuen Alternativen Hörerzahlen, ne, die gefallen mir direkt sehr viel besser. Man sieht ähm,
dass das hier ein Tag der netzpolitischen Devotion und Hingabe ist. Wir rufen den äh was ist heute den vierundzwanzigsten Januar aus als internationalen Tag der netzpolitischen Hingabe.
Netz politische Hingabe. Meinst du, Opfer,
Die Opferbereitschaft muss schon sehr hoch sein, wenn man sich heutzutage noch in der Debatte beteiligen möchte, so.
Ja.
Weil die die Steaks steigen auch irgendwie äh an, ne? Es ist irgendwie lange, ist jetzt langsam kein Spaß mehr.
Nee, es ist äh es ist leider irgendwie nicht mehr so witzig, aber la.
Ich meine, am Anfang haben wir das ja nur so aus Lifestyle Erwährungen gemacht. Ey, komm, lass mal über Netzpolitik reden und so. Ist gerade voll hip, äh.
Ja und jetzt sind wir hier, jetzt haben wir unser Leben gewidmet und die internationalen Feiertag. Uns gewidmet. So, den haben wir auch verdient. Wir haben heute eine Sendung gemacht.
Ähm dann lassen sie mal mit ein bisschen äh Meter äh Kram anfangen.
Nachdem uns äh aufgefallen ist, dass wir einen Monat lang keine Logbuchnetzpolitik Shirts verschickt haben, äh mussten wir mal in die Metaperspektive. Weil, nee, wir haben die Leute einen Monat warten lassen.
Gut, wir haben ja auch geschrieben, ist, es wird ein bisschen dauern,
für eure unterschiedliche Einheiten von äh bisschen, na ja das war halt diese
Post äh Kongressphase, wo wir uns jetzt auch nicht groß rausreden. Das äh hat ein bisschen geschleift und es gab noch ein paar äh Datenkonvertierungsprobleme
Jetzt allerdings ist die Order ergangen, wer sein bestelltes Shirt jetzt äh der zweiten Runde noch nicht erhalten hat, sollte.
Müsste morgen oder übermorgen.
Müsste das eigentlich mittrifft in dieser Sendung mehr oder weniger beginnend anzukommen.
Also die zweite Branche ist äh versendet und es gibt jetzt noch einige wenige Reste äh einige wenige Restshirts, die wir jetzt auch nochmal online gestellt haben.
Und zwar für die Männers haben wir noch äh S und M, sechs und drei Stück. Ein XL.
Das war's, ja? Also äh bei den Männern gibt's jetzt wirklich eine also die kaufen sie jetzt oder nie, also die werden wir wahrscheinlich nicht nachproduzieren oder neu machen ähm.
Zumindest jetzt nicht in der Form.
Beenden nächste. Mehr machen wir andere.
Eure Gelegenheit beim ersten Mal dabei gewesen zu sein.
Und bei den Frauen gibt's aber, ne, die haben offenbar weniger diese Shirts zu Weihnachten und zu Geburtstag bekommen. Bei den Frauen gibt's alle Größen noch SML und XL,
auch wieder nur in einstelligen Mengen drei S, ein M, vier L, sechs XL,
Das heißt, das sind wirklich jetzt noch Restkontingente und die hauen wir jetzt irgendwie raus und äh dann ist auch gut. Das heißt, wir werden und da sagen wir jetzt schon, der Verkauf dieser Shirts wird entweder passieren, wenn alle verkauft sind,
oder irgendwann oder dann irgendwann im Februar. Weil das Ding ist, man will einfach nicht jede jeden Tag mit drei Shirts oder mit einem Shirt oder mit fünf Shirts äh zur Post gehen, sondern man wartet natürlich, bis man irgendwie eine,
ein Paket fertig hat, holt sich dann so einen Einkaufswagen, wie man ja in jedem Supermarkt, also das ist zum Beispiel was, wo wo wirklich Fußpreisstabilität geblieben ist, ne? Einkaufswagen kostet einen Euro. Kriegst du seit detwas vorher eine Mark,
Eins zu eins unkonvertiert ein Euro, das ist wirklich ein Produkt, ja? Und auch in Qualität, die wirklich was hält, so einen holt man sich dann eben, ne? Das ist wirklich günstig und fährt äh zur Post.
Und dann äh kannst du es eigentlich einen Wegwerfartikel, so einen Einkaufswagen, ne?
Deine Pankermentalität bricht schon wieder durch. Vidos.
So dann und dann werden die halt versendet und das nächste Mal wird das halt im Februar passieren. Es gibt jetzt noch ein paar wenige kann man jetzt bestellen. Das wollten wir sagen. Aber wir wollten aber auch so ein bisschen mit Meter Meter Preter,
Perspektive auf das äh ziehen, was wir hier machen. Und ich muss, ich fange jetzt einfach mal an,
mir ist irgendwie erst bei der LMP zweihundert relativ, also in der in der Nachfahr in der mentalen Verarbeitung der LMP zweihundert äh so ein bisschen klar geworden, was wir hier eigentlich über die Jahre äh angerichtet haben.
Na ähm mit einem halbwegs ähm.
Also mit einem Programm, dessen Anspruch glaube ich dann doch über dem Durchschnitt liegt von der von den Themen, die wir behandeln.
Und vom Lied vom politischen.
Über dem Durchschnitt von was.
Na, ich habe gerade auf Spiegel online geguckt. Die haben irgendwie diese komischen Menschen, die sie da in den Dschungel gefahren haben in der Fotoserie drüber gehabt. Also das da da das ist irgendwie das ist irgendwie noch im Durchschnitt offenbar,
da sind wir dann doch drüber.
Nun mal, solange wir noch keine Panorama äh Sektion hier eingeführt haben, ist noch alles zu retten.
Ich würde ihn vorsichtig schätzen, dass die Themen, die wir behandeln vom.
Sag ich mal, ein ein überdurchschnittliches politisches Interesse bei unter den hörenden Voraussetzungen,
Und wahrscheinlich auch in einer überdurchschnittlichen Tiefe behandelt werden,
Das war mir vorher nicht unbedingt klar, weil wir ja immer in unserer Filterblase waren und uns jetzt irgendwie so ein bisschen die Realität da draußen, also so man irgendwie damit konfrontiert wird, dass vielleicht nicht
die gesamte Gesellschaft sich so ähm,
so genau oder überhaupt in der Tiefe mit politischen Themen auseinandersetzt. Und auch mit der dieser Tat Detailverliebtheit, denn äh was wir machen ist ja jetzt häufig auch nicht das größte Problem, dem die Menschheit gegenüber steht.
Ja, also ich find's aber es ist es ist immer ein bisschen einfach und und vielleicht auch auch billig,
Dingen, die sich nicht mit ernstem Kram und sogenannten wichtigen Graben auseinandersetzen, so ein bisschen die Daseinsberechtigung äh,
abzusprechen, ne? Meine, wenn man danach geht, könnte man ja im Prinzip auch Fußball komplett äh weglassen, nur ab, aber was würde dann passieren.
Das ist.
Also das ist äh das bindende Potential solcher äh,
kulturellen Selbstbeschäftigung und dieses dieses Fliehen in in so ein krisenfreies
so 'n kleinen krisenfreien Tunnel, der zumindest so 'n bisschen Auszeit auch gibt von diesem Bombardement des des Gesamtelends, was man sonst noch so wahrnimmt. Ähm, das hat auch so seine Berechtigung.
Nicht genau wo du hin willst, willst du jetzt, also willst du jetzt sagen Logbuch Nestpolitik könnte fast so wichtig sein wie Fußball? Oder möchtest du sagen.
Ich finde, du solltest in den Dschungel Linus. Zehn Promis. Seid ihr bestenfalls Probis?
Nee, aber wofür worauf willst du denn da aus? Also ich äh.
Ich will erstmal auf gar nichts hinaus. Ich will die Debatte äh hier weiterführen. So. Ich meine, du beklagst dich da drüber, dass das übers Dschungel-Camp berichtet wird.
Nein, ich habe ein, nein, ich habe mich nicht darüber beklagt. Ich finde das
wichtig, dass über sowas berichtet wird, weil wenn da nicht berichtet, wenn darüber nicht berichtet würde, hätte ich das nie mitbekommen, dass es das gibt. Ich habe seit, ich habe in meinem Leben keinen Fernseher besessen,
So, ich habe irgendwann mal, ich glaube, als Teenager mal versucht, irgendwie so ein, so ein äh so ein, so einen Taschenfernseher oder sowas irgendwie in meinen Besitz zu bringen. Ähm,
Aber sonst habe ich, ich habe nie über ein ein Wohnzimmer oder ein Kinderzimmer oder eine Wohnung verfügt, in der sich ein Fernseher gefunden hat.
Sind die ganzen Brot und Spiele äh.
Das alle, ja und wir sind fernab davon und führen irgendwie so ein, versuchen irgendwie ein, also ich zumindest versuche irgendwie
mich mit trotzdem mit dem mit dieser Gesellschaft auseinanderzusetzen, ne? Und dann kann man natürlich dann kommt auch immer wieder. Ja, hier sitzt er im Elfenbeinturm und ihr wisst ja überhaupt nicht, was die Leute auf der Straße beschäftigt und wie wie auch immer, also ich mir ist irgendwie nur bei diesem
bei dieser NMP zweihundert, das wollte ich eigentlich sagen, aufgefallen, dass wir offenbar mit dem, was wir hier machen, irgendwie ein paar Leute erreichen.
Dass das.
Dass sich das sehr, dass mich das natürlich sehr freut, weil man manchmal auch so ein bisschen den Eindruck hat ähm.
Dass da draußen irgendwie alles gerade einstürzt und dass es irgendwie ähm.
Dass die Zeit vorbei ist, in der irgendwie vielleicht noch ein bisschen versucht wird, rational über ein paar Sachen nachzudenken.
Ja gut, ich würde das jetzt nicht so überraschen, dass mich das jetzt nicht so überrascht hat. Also ich nehme das ja schon ein bisschen äh äh länger wahr und das so besonders nicht nur, aber besonders in diesem Podcastumfeld schon sich auch eine
aufgeklärte und aufklärungsbereite,
Gruppe von von Menschen dieser Gesellschaft versammelt und in gewisser Hinsicht das Medium eben nutzt, um aktiv an so einer Debatte teilzunehmen, die sie durchaus eben auch als,
Gewinn, Fortbildung, Motivation für sich sieht und insofern äh spielen wir hier eine kleine Rolle,
in dieser Aktivierung ähm von der du wahrscheinlich jetzt auch äh sprechen möchtest, die wir beide als erforderlich,
halten.
Ich habe die.
In diesem Jahr.
Ich habe die Tage so ein Interview äh gehabt mit so einem.
So ein Magazin. Da haben wir irgendwie drüber gesprochen, also war ein längeres Gespräch, was weiß gar nicht, ob die das jemals als Interview noch verwerten können, war ein längeres Gespräch. Und da haben wir irgendwie so darüber uns unterhalten, was denn irgendwie.
Was macht denn jetzt den Chaos-Computerclub aus, ne,
total schwierige Frage, kannst du, kannst du überhaupt nicht beantworten. Ähm habe ich aber dann mal versucht, ja diese längere Zeit selber drüber geredet und mir selber beim Reden zugehört, bis es irgendwie selber mal gecheckt habe. Ähm,
dass es eigentlich das einzige Verbindende Element da ist. Ne, also,
sind die politischen Bereiche, sind die ganzen Make-up Kramen, irgendwie Security-Kram dass die Leute was lernen wollen.
Erstens, was lernen wollen, wirklich? Und zweitens gelerntes Wissen teilen wollen,
Ja, also so eine, so diese, das ist irgendwie das, was allen gemein ist, so. Man interessiert sich für Vorgänge.
Man möchte sie ergründen, man will diese, was man da gelernt oder mitgenommen hat, irgendwie mit anderen teilen. Und nächste Woche kommt was Neues,
oder nächstes Jahr kommt was Neues. Kommt drauf an, wie nördlich man ist,
und Dinge werden irgendwie immer darauf abgeklopft, da sie irgendwie zu verbessern. Ne, also irgendwie so
das ist das einzige, was mir als als verbindendes Element aufgefallen ist. Also sei das irgendwie, ne? So die die wahnsinnigen vom Wock,
die einfach ihren Prozess da immer weiter optimieren und,
immer besser und immer mehr und immer mehr Konferenzen und immer mehr dokumentieren und immer mehr
Wissen bereitstellen, ja? Und und den letzten Prozess noch optimieren und wir brauchen eine eine rote LED oben und ein Intercom und da brauchen wir alles und das machen wir jetzt perfekt.
Aber die kommen auch nicht an den Punkt, dass sie sagen, so jetzt haben wir das gemacht und jetzt ist es gut und jetzt lehnen wir uns zurück und blicken auf unser Lebenswerk. Sondern die bauen immer besser.
Sind sie auch noch jung.
Nein, ist doch egal, ne? Aber die die ziehen das weiter durch und die wollen mehr lernen und besser machen,
Und äh in diesem Security-Bereich hast du das natürlich auch ähm und in dem, in dem politischen Bereich bilde ich mir ein, hast du es auch und im in,
Das ist eigentlich das, was ihnen, warum ich mich auch in dieser Community so wohl fühle, weil das auch die wird auch immer wieder neu in Frage gestellt,
Was geht mir das bei dir auf den Sack? Dass du andauernd Sachen besser machen willst und nie zufrieden bist? Ich habe mir wieder hier diese diese Freakshow angehört, wo du wieder ein vier Stunden lang nur am Meckern warst über den Kongress, ja? Aber natürlich genau die Punkte gefunden hast, wo man das besser machen kann.
Ja? Ähm und das ist irgendwie, glaube ich, das, was irgendwie für mich eine was für mich progressive Haltung ausdrückt, dass man.
Lernen will, dass man besser machen will, dass man irgendwie vorankommen will und vor allem wissbegierig ist. Und ich habe den Eindruck.
Dass das immer eine Minderheit war ein Menschen, die Bock hatte Neues zu lernen,
Und das ist irgendwie das, was mir äh was ich mir irgendwie einbilde, was was irgendwie der der
Der CCC so ein bisschen Sammelbecken für geworden ist, äh was äh diese Podcastszene Sammelbecken für geworden ist, für Leute, die.
Mehr die vorankommen wollen, in irgendeiner Form, ja.
Und nicht irgendwie sagen, okay, äh Problem so und so. Wir müssen jetzt dieses oder jenes runterschreiben, äh woand alles andere war auch schon immer Kacke und äh und dieses Miesmachertum,
an den Tag legen, was sich jetzt in zunehmendem Maße wahrnehme,
dass ich das in zunehmenden Maße wahrnehme, heißt nicht unbedingt das da zugenommen hat. Der kann aber auch gut sein, dass das seit Ewigkeiten schon da war, dass ich da nur noch nicht so drauf aufmerksam geworden bin. Aber da draußen sind echt,
'ne ganze Reihe Miesmacher unterwegs und ich bin ähm erstaunt teilweise dass denen das nicht selber irgendwann langweilig geworden ist damit.
Die was mies machen.
Das ist denen völlig egal.
Ach so, du meinst es mies machen, um das mies machen.
Machen eigentlich, also wenn es gibt so Kandidaten, grade bei diesen Bloggern, ne, so die verbleibenden Blogger, das echt Leute, die den ganzen Tag auf ihren Blog nichts anderes machen, als sich an anderen Leuten abarbeiten,
das ist erstaunlich, mit welcher Werft die das machen. Und wie lange die sich eine einzelne Person abarbeiten, ja? Das so teilweise Blogger.
Ja gut, ich würde es jetzt nicht auf Blogger generalisieren, das findest du unter Podcastlandschaft auch, also ja ja.
Das hast du bei Journalisten, das hast du überall, ne? Aber du hast Menschen, die arbeiten sich mitunter jahrelang,
einer einzelnen Person ab. Ja, also die haben dann mehrere einzelne Personen, aber die begleiten die,
Also auch so unbedeutende Personen, ja? Also Personen, die jetzt wirklich weit davon entfernt sind, irgendwie eine Revolution runterzubrechen oder so
die dann der jahrelang verfolgt werden und jedes Mal, wenn die was twittern, dann werden da lange Artikel drüber geschrieben, was das für dumme Idioten sind und und dass die wahrscheinlich schlechten Sex haben und und was nicht als und du denkst dir wirklich, womit setzen die sich den ganzen Tag auseinander
Und dann hast du, dann merkst du, dass die offenbar auch eine ähm eine Reichweite haben mit,
Mit am Ende nix anderem als inhaltslosen Athrominam. Und ist mir echt also,
meine Güte, so. Ich ich glaube, die haben bei weitem nicht die Reichweite, die man ähm,
die man ihnen zuspricht, weil offenbar existieren diese Personen seit Jahrzehnten und man haben.
Werden halt auch nur immer älter, einsamer und frustrierter, aber es ist schon ähm.
Es ist hier wie erstaunlich. Also ich bin ich ich mir fehlt da so ein bisschen die also ich ich sehe das einfach nur und denke mir so boah krass ey. Die haben ihr Leben lang nichts.
Irgendwie positives Mal.
Uns natürlich auch selber uns an diesen Leuten abarbeiten, finde ich jetzt genauso müßig.
Nein, nein, nein, aber genau in dem, in dem Vergleich sehe ich halt irgendwie so diese Podcastszene und so und denke mir so, boah krass so, es gibt sie noch,
Die Leute, die sich irgendwie mit Dingen immer noch auseinandersetzen wollen, die immer noch irgendwie äh Fakten hungrig sind in der postfaktischen Welt. Die Debatten führen in Zeiten der des
des Shitstorms, ja? Also da das meine ich irgendwie da, das freut mich irgendwie. Und das ist mir irgendwie durch durch diese LMP zweihundert und durch diesen Kongress irgendwie mal wieder,
Sehr sehr verspätet klar geworden.
Und jetzt die Frage, was machen wir da daraus, ne? Weil ähm der Fluch möget ihr interessanten Zeiten leben.
Die hat uns auf jeden Fall ja alt.
Der ist auf jeden Fall dieses Jahr mal äh so richtig äh aktuell. Gar keine Frage und wir werden auch in dieser Sendung noch viel über
Leute reden, die man eigentlich gar nicht reden möchte, aber die leider einem so dermaßen in äh in den Weg kommen, dass dass man's halt einfach thematisieren muss,
Und das ist natürlich auch ein gewisser Gesicht frustrierend, das ist ein gewisser Gesicht auch teilweise mobilisierend, wenn vielleicht auch zu zu spät oder am falschen Ort oder eben teilweise auch die falsche äh Art und Weise
Fragt sich nur, was was bedeutet das jetzt für uns? Also wenn wir jetzt quasi über uns, als als als Projekt, als Podcast Projekt äh,
sprechen, welch vor welchen Herausforderungen stehen wir? Und vor allem wie, wie stehen wir zu diesen Herausforderungen.
Welche Herausforderungen siehst du dann.
Na ja.
Wo siehst du uns in fünf Jahren.
Beim goldenen Thron.
Also ich sitze auf Synthrom und du sitzt auf so einem Stoffpferd, ne.
Und halte dir das Mikrofon. Nee, sag mal, ernsthaft.
Also.
Also mit Angaben über die Zukunft ist es ja so ein so ein, so ein Ding und ehrlich gesagt, ich find's schon äh schwierig genug über dieses Jahr nachzudenken. Ich denke, zwanzig siebzehn sollte ja jetzt erstmal der Fokus sein, weil wir haben ja ganz offenbar.
Einiges zu bewältigen in diesem Jahr, insbesondere die
Eskalation von äh wichtigen Wahlen, ja, die durchaus wegweisend sein können in die eine wie auch in die andere Richtung, da ist natürlich zunächst einmal die Präsidentschaftswahl in
Frankreich zu ähm nennen, die sicherlich auf Europa den großen Einfluss haben wird und natürlich dann auch die Bundestagswahl,
hier irgendwann im September, gibt's eigentlich schon einen Termin, ne.
Ich glaube, dass heute der vierundzwanzigste sein oder so und das war irgendwie dann ist er irgendeiner gemeint, da wäre in Berlin Marathon oder sowas. Weiß ich aber nicht genau. Irgendwie sowas.
Äh ja, vierundzwanzigster voraussichtlich. Ich am Tag des Marathons, das wäre auch blöd. Genau, so und was erleben wir jetzt? Wir erleben eine Phase der Verunsicherung.
Eine Verunsicherung auch dieser äh Szene, von der du gerade gesprochen hast, auch eine Verunsicherung von von Leuten, die vieles auch für unverrückbar und unverschiebbar gehalten haben,
Das mögen eins einzelne anders gesehen haben, ja, dass das nichts äh ewig hält et cetera, aber ähm,
Ich denke, dass viele schon davon ausgegangen sind, dass wir zumindest Deutschland doch in auf sehr stabilen äh Grundfesten gebaut sind nach fünfzig Jahren
offener Demokratieerfahrung ist, dürfen wir halt feststellen, dass eben sich kleine Fehler schnell rechnen, rechnen und dass,
Ja, auf einmal nichts mehr so in Stein gemeißelt zu sein scheint wie das vielleicht bis vor kurzem noch der Fall war.
Ja und die Frage ist natürlich wie wie begegnen wir dem, wie wie gehen wir damit um? Und äh weil du gerade auch den Club so erwähnt hast oder ich würde es mal so ein bisschen weiter auf diese ganze digitale Szene äh erweitern.
Was mir so ein bisschen zu denken gibt ist. Wir waren ja auch sind's auch noch teilweise,
Auch so eine so eine doch eine eine relativ selbstverliebte Szene auch immer gewesen, so. Der ganze Hacker
Geschichte, was fanden wir uns geil, ne? So in Neunzigern
da stand, da kam so die ganze Welt auf einen zugekrochen und musste irgendwie jeden Monat äh Abbitte leisten und sagen, ihr habt recht,
so Internet, Computer, Netzwerke, Sicherheit
Datenschutz, Privatsphäre, bla. Ich meine, man hat das Gefühl, seit zehn Jahren wird irgendwie in der Tagesschau nichts anderes runtertrompetet als das, was irgendwie der Club und äh vergleichbare Gruppen,
im Prinzip schon seit Mitte der achtziger Jahre rausposaunt haben. Man fühlte sich doch einfach mal richtig gut. Ne, dazu noch der ganze Hacker kult, dann kam auch noch ein Matrix und wenn man einfach mal die geilsten.
Und was damit aber auch einherging, war immer so eine so eine besserwisserische Grundhaltung, so ein,
Wir haben's doch äh immer schon gesagt und wir haben's ja schon immer äh gewusst und warum hört er uns nicht zu und äh aus dieser,
leichten Selbstverliebtheit heraus entsteht natürlich auch schnell so eine überheb
Überheblichkeit, die aber dann auch gepaart ist so mit so einem rauenden Allwissen so. Ja, die Dinge sind ja anders als ihr denkt und äh wir blicken ja
die dahinter liegenden Strukturen und äh wir zweifeln die Machtstrukturen, die sich vor unserem
TV-Bild aufbauen, die zweifeln wir ja an und wir blicken ja dahinter und wir haben ja irgendwie sehr viel mehr Ahnung was da passiert. Und dann geht das eben auch teilweise.
Schnell in dieses Verschwörungs äh theoretische Feld rein, ja, wo dann eine einige ähm,
nicht unbedingt jetzt aus dieser Szene, aber zumindest aus dem Umfeld heraus,
dann auch irgendwie schnell nicht abgedreht sind. Ich hab das so gemerkt als diese Freiheit statt Angstdemos irgendwie losging nach so ein, zwei, drei Jahren, das hat dann nicht lange gedauert und dann hat sie dann schon so hier diese Info-War äh Freundchen da äh im im Schlepptau und und und sonstige Vögel
also somit mit so einem vollkommen übersteigerten und übertriebenen Weltblick
auf einmal auftraten, wo man sich dann schon fragte, so ähm ja, also,
Dinge in Zweifel ziehen, das ist ja irgendwie alles schon in Ordnung, aber seid ihr euch sicher, dass ihr hier noch noch das richtige Maß findet.
Durch, ne, durch ein Eleven und so weiter kam das dann nochmal so richtig in Rotation und äh jetzt,
Habe ich so manchmal so den Eindruck, dass das eben auch schon einfach ein bisschen überdreht ist
und dass das eben auch teilweise in äh in so eine Eigendynamik reingekommen ist, wo man sagen muss, das ist jetzt auch nicht gut und das ist äh das befördert jetzt äh nicht unbedingt unseren Wunsch nach
ähm stabilen offenen, fairen Verhältnissen in unserer Gesellschaft.
Und deswegen denke ich, dass es einfach an der Zeit ist, hier einfach auch eine nicht nur eine Haltung auszusprechen, sondern auch.
Zu bilden und und und vielleicht auch mal neu zu formulieren und dabei auch sich von dem ein oder anderen zu trennen, was man vielleicht bisher für ganz äh putzig gehalten hat und ne. Man fühlt sich ja so geil,
ähm oder einfach mal auch sieht, wir lagen auch nicht immer richtig. Gerade so diese Einschätzung, ich habe das glaube ich schon ein paar Mal erwähnt, aber,
liegt mir auch so ein bisschen schwer auf dem Herzen, ne? Gerade so dieser Art und Weise, dann werden wir auch nochmal drüber reden, wie sich das so mit den sozialen Medien entwickelt hat. Da haben wir einfach eine Fehleinschätzung gehabt,
Da sind wir einfach ähm in so einem Technikoptimismus äh losmarschiert und haben gesagt, ach, umso mehr Beteiligung und umso mehr alle dabei sind,
ja. Und haben irgendwie auf die konservativen Politiker eingedroschen, die die ganze Zeit nur noch von ähm,
Hass im Netz geredet haben, was dann irgendwie auch erstmal äh beiseite gelegt wurde und so und ihr blickt ja hier nicht auf die Chancen, so und er schaut ja nur auf die Risiken.
Also ich weiß ähm,
Ja, aber in dem, in eben diesem Interview, ne? Ähm, also ich weiß nicht ganz genau, ob ich, also ich würde nicht behaupten, dass ich irgendwie ein besonderer Freund, der,
ein besonders kritikloser Befürworter der sozialen Medien war.
Oder gewesen sei. Ich meine, ich bin immer noch einer äh ich habe immer noch kein Faceboo,
Account und bin, glaube ich, einer der wenigen, der da äh oder auf jeden Fall inzwischen in Deutschland wahrscheinlich in in meiner Altersgruppe, in der Minderheit. Also, dass wir da, dass wir da irgendwie Kritik frei den Weg äh gewiesen hätten.
Ja gut, aber ich meine auf Twitter, hast du auch deinen Spaß? So ist es ja nicht.
Spaß würde ich das nicht nennen. Also ähm.
Mittlerweile nicht, mehr. Ähm ich hatte den ganz ganz ohne Frage. So, habe den auch teilweise immer noch, aber es ändert sich.
Das stimmt. Also was ich eigentlich nur ich glaube, was ich würde hier nur gerne ergänzen, wir haben schon davor immer gewarnt, dass das nicht unbedingt eine gute Idee ist, wenn der ähm,
wenn der äh vielbeschworene Athener Dorfplatz, ja? Jetzt plötzlich eine Shopping-Mall ist mit Hausordnung und äh Werbefinanzierung. Ja, ich glaube
das ist ja kurzgefasst das Problem, was wir jetzt eigentlich haben. So, ne? Wir haben irgendwie die Idee war, was weiß ich hier, Global Village und weltweite Demokratie, Austausch von Wissen und so weiter
Weil, wie genau mit dieser, mit dieser positiven Utopie, die wir eigentlich immer hatten, ne? Kommunikation und freies Wissen und Tauschen und lernen wollen, bringt uns alle voran,
Davon ausgegangen sind, dass wenn wir jetzt dieses Internet an alle tragen, dass keine andere,
keine andere ähm Entwicklung gibt als dass die Leute da drin auch aufgehen in Austausch und Austausch äh und in Austausch und Aufklärung und Lernen und tauschen,
Und das war glaube ich so ähm,
die Fehler die die katastrophale Fehleinschätzung so dieser neunziger Jahre Philosophen auch. Das waren ja nicht nur äh wir, die das gesagt haben, sondern ähm.
Ja, wir wollten so Marx erklären und die so was ist mit Dschungel-Camp und wie hat Bayern gesp.
Ja und und vor allem dann irgendwann so, dass dann eben große Konzerne gesagt haben, ja echt wäre geiles Ding, hast recht, das kaufen wir.
Ne, diese diese Demokratie, dieses Demokratie-Ideal, was ich ja so oft versuche zu beschreiben und wahrscheinlich immer noch so schlecht in Worte fasse, ne? Also dieser dieser liberale Austausch
Ideen und Wissens und unter rationalen Vorzeichen, was eben einfach noch nie stattgefunden hat, äh hat auch jetzt nicht stattgefunden. Und inzwischen bilden wir halt einen größeren Teil unserer Öffentlichkeit äh auf Facebook ab,
also das, was der, ich glaube, echt so dieser Dorfplatz ist halt jetzt eine privat geführte Shoppingware mit Hausworten.
Und wer da was zu sagen hat, muss muss sich das kaufen, ne? Also die die Speakers Corner kann's halt jetzt höchstbietend in dieser Shopping-Wahl so ungefähr.
Ja, aber es ist doch nicht so sehr, ich meine, siehst du jetzt tatsächlich so dieses kapitalistische Element, als das Kernproblem, das ist es ja eigentlich nicht.
Ich sehe na ja, also ich glaube, dass,
Das Kapital, ich weiß nicht, ob das Kernproblem ist, ne? Also auf jeden Fall eines der,
Zentralen ähm eine der zentralen Entwicklungen, die dieser hoffreier Austausch, freie Welt und so weiter so ein bisschen entgegensteht.
Na ja, ich sehe das Problem eher da drin, dass dieser freie Austausch jetzt halt in einem Maße äh stattfindet, in dem er halt ähm selbst sich,
hochschaukelt und ähm sozusagen dadurch eine eine Massendynamik entwickelt, wo die Leute halt einfach nur noch hinterher rennen. Und zwar weit entfernt von jeglicher Aufklärung. Aber auch in gewisser Hinsicht.
Gut, also dann die Kapitalismus-These, die können wir da gerne noch mit allen äh Flech.
Die hast du jetzt Kapitalismus genannt? Ich würde sie eher Zentralisierungsthese nennen. Also was was am Ende,
nicht gut getan hat oder was am Ende vielen vielen im Weg steht ist äh so eine Plattform Zentralisierung und es gibt ja also es gibt wenige,
Beispiele.
Die noch wirklich vergleichbar sind mit mit dem, was wo wir jetzt quasi, was wir irgendwann mal das Geile am Internet äh fanden.
Ja, wieso, aber ich meine, Zentralisierung hast du in dem Moment auch schon, wo du irgendwie mit Websites äh äh daher kommst, die irgendwie populärer Anlaufstellen sind. Das gab's bei den Nerds genauso.
Also äh das ist halt einfach ein, ein, ein, ein Effekt einer sich äh verbreitenden Vernetzung. Klar kannst du im Prinzip von jedermann zu jeder Mann, jeder Frau, jeder Frau irgendwie einzelne Nachrichten schicken und das findet ja auch statt, ja? Trotz alledem
sucht man sich natürlich dann seine neuen Agoren
Ja, die gab's ja auch vorher, das war dann halt vorher die Zeitung und das Fernsehen und jetzt sind es eben andere Orte und jetzt können diese Orte eben auch mit sehr viel ähm weniger Profil schnell aufsteigen
weil die Zutrittsbedingungen sich einfach geändert haben. Das halte ich aber für einen normalen,
Vorgang und per se jetzt erstmal nicht schlecht. Das war vorher bei den Nerds im Global Village auch nicht anders,
klar, ich meine, wo gehst du hin mit deiner Kommunikation, wenn du dich austauschen willst? Da wo alle anderen sind, so. Die populärste Mailbox, die äh populärste Webseite, da war's dann halt lange Zeit meist Lash dot, so,
relativ schnell auch sein äh Flamewar und Trollproblem bekommen hat,
versucht hat und vielleicht teilweise auch geschafft hat, mit technischen Maßnahmen in den Griff zu bekommen, aber es war ja nur eine Frage der Zeit, bist äh bist du eben ein Slash für,
alle möglichen politischen Grundrichtungen hast. So und du kriegst halt da nicht alle auf die aufgeklärte Seite. Das ist jetzt einfach mal so ein.
So ein Ergebnis einer einer technologischen Entwicklung, die sehr rasant äh verlaufen ist und,
Der wird, denke ich, eben auch selber lange Zeit.
So unkritisch würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, also Kritik war ja schon immer äh auch mit dabei, aber ich finde, man hat sich quasi auf,
Einige Nebenkriegsschauplätze konzentriert, die vielleicht das wahre Problem so nicht abbilden. So und jetzt jetzt haben wir eine Situation, in der sich eben politische Strömungen äh schnell aufschaukeln können, in denen vor allem Leute dran teilnehmen, deren,
Ziele eher Systemauflösenden Charakter haben. Das ist ja so ein bisschen das, was wir derzeit äh beobachten.
Also ähm nee, Moment, Dörfel.
Da kann man halt so drüber nachdenken, ob das jetzt gut ist.
Also Systemauflösenden Charakter hatten auch viele Ideen,
die diese liberale Netzphilosophie vorhergebracht hat. Da hat keiner gesagt wir haben die wenigsten gesagt, ja geil da können wir ein Parlamen
zwei Parteiensystem super geil die nächsten tausend Jahre drin zementieren. Da wurden ja schon Fundamente
der herrschenden politischen Verhältnisse in Frage gestellt, ganz klar. Ähm,
Ich glaube, womit wir heute zu tun haben, ist eher äh das sich diese Mechanismen angeeignet werden,
von Leuten, die nicht unbedingt, sage ich mal, zu Freiheit aller und zum Vorteil aller agieren. Und ähm,
Systemauflösen weiß ich nicht. Also den
Diesen Charakter habe ich auf jeden Fall an vielen anderen Stellen ebenso erlebt in in dieser Szene. Das machst ja fast den Eindruck, als wäre der, als wäre jetzt irgendwie die die Position der der
von CCC und und ähnlichen Vertretern in den letzten zwanzig Jahren äh Staatsstabilisieren und und Facebook bejahend gewesen. Al.
Nee, Facebook bejahend nicht, aber staatsragend in gewisser Hinsicht schon. Also ich denke, dass der, dass der, dass der Club im Speziellen doch sehr viel konservativer ist im positiven Sinne,
Ja? Uns ging's immer um eine Erhaltung von demokratischen Strukturen. Uns ging's immer um eine Erhaltung von Freiheit. Es ist ja nicht so, dass wir.
Einen Ausbau nicht Erhaltung.
Ja, aber,
Jetzt kümmern wir uns um um Worte streiten, was ich sagen will ist, es ist nicht so, dass wir generell irgendwie die Revolution ausgerufen haben und jetzt äh sozusagen alle Köpfe rollen wollten, äh sehen wollten, sondern äh wir haben einen einen kritischen, teilweise sehr kritischen
Diskurs geführt im Rahmen eines Systems, was wir grundsätzlich für Erhaltenswert halten,
Und da stehe ich auch nach wie vor dazu zu dieser Sichtweise, dass es auch meine Haltung an dieser Stelle, weil ich auch eben nicht so richtig erkennen kann, dass wir jetzt hier im Großen und Ganzen so schlecht dastehen noch.
Ja, klar, man kann vieles und muss, vieles äh kritisieren und man muss alle
Entwicklung immer im Blick haben und selbstverständlich kann man kritisch über militärische Beteiligung, Waffenlieferung, politische Ränke, Schmiede
Einflussnahme im In und Ausland Geheimdienstaktivitäten Unwesen von Verfassungsschutz et cetera. Was wir hier auch oft
thematisieren. Das kann und muss man alles auf den Tisch prägen. Trotzdem,
bewegt sich unsere Kritik in einem Grundwunsch des ähm der der Verbesserung dessen, was wir haben.
Also Tim, du stehst, ich glaube, wir haben jetzt festgestellt, dass also wir haben jetzt für unsere Verfassungsschutzzuhörer klargestellt, dass wir uns die freiheitlich demokratische Grundordnung äh gefällt,
und wir sie nicht abschaffen wollen.
Ja, aber beim Verfassungsschutz selber sind wir uns nicht so sicher.
Und ist deswegen auch kein Verbotsverfahren. Für Lokbodenspolitik geben muss.
Ach komm, dann würden wir wirklich auf eins Komma fünf Millionen Hörer kommen.
Ja, der ähm genau, aber okay, jetzt haben wir, jetzt haben wir lange äh Meter diskutiert, wir.
Tut ein bisschen weh, das so zu formulieren, ne, aber ich denke, das ist, das ist ja.
Ja, ich würde auch gerne stimmt tatsächlich so, also ich mir ich finde ich würde auch im Detail da trotzdem also mir im Detail tatsächlich widersprechen. Es geht darum ähm.
Es geht schon darum, dass ich mir das System unseres Zusammenlebens.
Noch sehr viel besser vorstellen kann. Die Veränderungen darin.
Bestünden aber würden nicht unbedingt einen kompletten Abbau äh von von Demokratie ähm und sozialer Marktwirtschaft erfordern.
Die hätten eine, wären eine sehr zentrale, fundamentale Neuausrichtung dergleichen.
Heißen aber nicht, dass man sie abschaffen muss,
Und ähm ich glaube, das ist das, was du äh was du meinst. Also es wäre, denke schon, dass der CC weitestgehend für,
im Sinne im weitestgehenden Sinne revolutionäre Änderungen eingestanden ist und revolutionär andere Perspektiven, die aber nicht bedeutet haben,
lasst uns die Demokratie oder das Parlament abschaffen.
Und vor allem die immer davon ausgegangen sind, lasst uns ähm.
Mehr nachdenken, mehr mehr Ratio und irgendwie mehr. Und auf dieser Idee dann auch mehr Demokratie.
Wagen, ja? Also wir wollen da oder man wollte, dass oder man will immer noch das Niveau der politischen Auseinandersetzung anheben.
Und auf der Höhe dieses Niveaus äh zu größeren zu größeren, zu größerer Freiheit marschieren. Ne? Und man kann natürlich, ich glaube, dass grundsätzlich nicht geht oder dass es schief geht.
Ähm das Niveau der politischen Auseinandersetzung niedrig zu halten. Dafür ist das ganze Thema einfach zu komplex. Man kann ähm sich immer eine schöne Platitüde bereitstellen,
und kann die dann halt, ne, mit wenigen Worten ähm oder auch mit vielen Worten, äh aber mit wenig Inhalt irgendwie vertreten,
Oder man kann sich, man kann den, man kann den Willen haben, sich mit der Komplexität des politischen Gefühles auseinanderzusetzen und in diesem Gefüge zu sagen, okay, aber wir wollen trotzdem wollen wir, ne?
Zu mehr Freiheit. Was ist denn, wie können wir hier,
mehr ähm mehr äh politischen Einfluss für die Individuen äh bereitstellen. Aber und wie können wir hier äh mehr.
Individuelle Entfaltung ermöglichen, ne? Dumm natürlich, dass sich diese beiden Sachen äh immer mal wieder echt im Weg stehen,
nämlich dann, wenn du den Leuten offenbar mehr ähm Entscheidungsgewalt äh zur Verfügung stellst als äh und sie diese nutzen, um im Prinzip diese ihre Entscheidungsgewalt abzugeben,
ne? Also ähm sich.
Zum Beispiel.
Volksentscheid gegen die Interessen der Leute, ne? Dann dann kommen wir da, dann kommen wieder eben, dann dann hast du nämlich genau den Punkt, dass dann da irgendwie solche hm ähm ähm
Münchner Aristokraten oder sowas sagen, na sieht, ja. Äh wenn ihr dem Volk, äh ne, das die Möglichkeit gebt, so dann äh entscheiden die sich doch für den starken Mann oder sowas, ne? Und äh und,
dann,
Dann siehst du jetzt, war jetzt entmündigen die Linken äh die die Wähler oder so, ne? Wollen sagen jetzt Volksentscheid nur, wenn wir das wollen oder sowas, ne? Und ähm.
Das ist natürlich dann auch ein ein trauriges und zynisches Argument, da muss man natürlich dann auch im Prinzip sagen, ja klar, so wir wollen natürlich irgendwie mehr Liberalität haben,
Und zu dieser Liberalität gehört vor allem mehr politische, demokratische äh Geschaltungs und Einflussmöglichkeiten. Was machen wir aber.
Wenn diese Einflussmöglichkeiten eben genutzt werden um eigentlich Set abzuschaffen oder um.
Wieder zu einer einfachen Politik der Verblödung zu kommen. Und das ist das, was wir eigentlich gerade sehen. Und dann würde ich halt im so, jetzt haben wir so lange rumphilosophiert. Ich würde sagen, dass wir versuchen.
Die Leute mit ein paar alternativen Fakten mit ein paar alternativen Blicken auf Fakten, aber immer noch Fakten basiert, irgendwie zu ermündigen,
gibt's das Wort? Bemündigen. Das das ist glaube ich das, was wir versuchen.
Ja. Genau.
Und vor allem ja drüber nachdenken, wie man ähm Änderungen herbeiführen kann ohne Sicherheitslücken in diesem System aufzubauen, die dann von anderen, ja, ausgenutzt werden.
Für ihre eigene Agenda,
Weil im Prinzip, ne, ich will jetzt hier nicht mit so einem blöden Security vergleichen kommen so, aber sowas wie äh Trends wie die AfD et cetera, das das ist so die Malware äh,
im politischen Gefüge.
Also ich finde den Security-Vergleich noch nicht mal so schlecht, ne? Du guckst ja halt du, du du klopfst ein System auf Sicherheitslücken ab ähm und versuchst sie zu fixen,
Und ähm gleichzeitig,
versuchst du das System besser zu machen, ne? Also das kann man schon irgendwie so in diese Software, in diese Software ähm äh,
Perspektive bringt, ne? Beziehungsweise Ability erhöhen, willst du das System performanter machen? Äh willst du das System verbessern, ne.
Transparenter machen.
Transparenter machen, Open Source machen, vielleicht sogar und gleichzeitig wenn du eine Warebility hast, wird sie fixen. Ja, vielleicht ist das gar nicht so gar nicht so blöd. Und irgendwann äh machst du auch mal eine Version zwei null.
Über die du dann hoffentlich gar genug nachgedacht hast. Ja, weil so ein Riefereit, ne, kann er dann halt auch mal schnell äh nach hinten losgehen.
Tja, okay, also das versuchen wir.
Etwas für klausuliert, aber ich dachte ich dachte und denke mir jetzt schon seit Tagen und Wochen eigentlich,
ist einfach äh in diesem Jahr sehr wichtig seine eigenen Ansprüche zu formulieren und gewisse Haltung zu zeigen und das wollen wir hier auch machen,
und ich denke auch,
werden wir nicht damit durchkommen in diesem Jahr nur mit so einer Walldorf und die das Geschehen zu,
kommentieren. Ne, das machen wir hier auch mal, weil man braucht ja auch ein bisschen Comic-Release,
Aber all das alleine äh tut's halt nicht. Ist ja auch nicht so, dass jetzt nichts passiert. Es gibt verschiedene Gruppen,
und einzelne Personen, die wir hier auch oft vorgestellt und auch teilweise zu Gast hatten, die auf ihre Art und Weise hier was machen, aber ich denke, das ist halt äh einerseits noch weitere äh Initiativen braucht, aber es braucht vor allem auch so eine.
So ein Grundzusammenhalt all dieser Gruppen, die sich mit dem, wie wir's jetzt vielleicht gerade so ein bisschen formuliert haben, was wir als Anspruch und Haltung verstehen,
klarkommen und sich vor allem dann nicht in solchen Graben kämpfen,
aufhalten, ja? Ist ja gerade in so linken politischen Bewegungen immer sehr populär sich vor allem erstmal so untereinander zu zersetzen und zu schwächen, um dann eben möglichst schlecht dazustehen. Äh das können wir uns einfach dieses Jahr nicht erlauben,
Trotz alledem müssen wir eben auch schauen, dass jetzt reines äh Systembashing und ähm,
bisschen auch so dieses äh die die Wackeligkeit der der Gesellschaft in der sich jetzt gerade befindet nur für seine eigenen Ziele äh zu nutzen, auch nicht in Ordnung ist.
Ja vor allem dieses Wackeligkeit der Gesellschaft, dass äh jetzt aber da kommen wir gleich noch ein bisschen zur Wackeligkeit der Gesellschaft reden wir eh noch längere Zeit gleich drüber,
Die haben wir jetzt in voller Breite bekommen in den letzten fünf Tagen vier. Vier Tage ist vier Tage, die die Welt erschütterte.
Ja
Welt in Atem. Aber Tim.
Zum Einstieg erstmal so kleine gute Nachrichten. Hohe Gründe. Mhm.
Frohe Kunde ist auch wirklich frohe Kunde, Mensch, Shelty Manning kommt frei am siebzehnten Mai. Mit einer Haftstrafe von sieben statt fünfunddreißig Jahren. Das ist was Schönes.
Ja da hat äh wer's noch nicht mitbekommen hat Mister Obama seine Ausnahme,
Kompetenzen, die einen Präsident, wenn er den Abtritt äh hat, genutzt
Um Begnadigungen durchzuführen und ähm also zwei Kategorien, ne? Begnadigung und äh also entweder vollständige Freilassung oder zumindest Hafterlassung, also es sind so diese beiden Kategorien, in dem sich das abspielt,
Ja und äh die Liste war groß, also ich glaube, Obama hat jetzt alle Rekorde gebrochen mit insgesamt tausendfünfhundert solcher
Maßnahmen, die er eingeleitet hat, während die anderen Präsidenten nur so auf maximal sechshundert gebracht haben, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, habe grad keinen Link ähm.
Zur Hand. Ja und ähm keine Ahnung, wen das noch alles so getroffen hat, aber Chelsea Menning ist natürlich an der Stelle die ähm,
bekannteste Person, das haben wir ja auch schon mehrfach besprochen,
sie hat halt dieses Collateral Mördervideo quasi an Wiki Leaks geleitet und das kam dann halt heraus durch eine,
eigene Dummheit, nämlich eine äh ein Zugeständnis einer anderen,
Personen gegenüber diesem Adrenalin Lamo in einem Chat zu. Weiß gar nicht, wie es dazu gekommen ist. Auf jeden Fall fand es dort statt und dieser Asyl Lemo ist halt gleich zu den Behörden gegangen und hat gesagt, ja,
Volksverräter bitte einmal festnehmen, was dann auch geschah.
Werde ich einen interessanten Austausch mit Adrian Lemo. Ähm also.
Auf welchem Wege.
Twitter.
Hatst du Spaß, ja?
Die also als dieses.
Man muss vielleicht kurz dazu sagen, also Chelsea Mening hat kein äh keine ähm also erstens genau,
dieses Recht zur äh zum zum Gnadenerlass hat der US-Präsident Immer. Das ist nix, was er nur am Ende hat. Das.
Am Ende, weil sie dann keinen mehr auf den Sack kriegen dafür. Ne? Also es ist.
Sind dann auch egal sein kann.
Die lassen halt verurteilte Straftäter frei und setzen sich über haben die Möglichkeit äh über ein Urteil,
sich hinwegzusetzen von allen Gerichten, ne? Das ist schon irgendwie eine auch eine krasse Ausnahme vom Rechtsstaat und so weiter und äh entsprechend ähm.
Aufgeladen ist das.
Entsprechend aufgeladen ist das und entsprechend verantwortungsbewusst ist in der Regel auch der Umgang damit. So Chelsea Mening hatte ähm,
als damals noch als Bradley Mening diese verschiedenen äh,
Akte von Wissleblowing geleistet, die durchaus den USA natürlich ein richtiger Sand im Getriebe waren
Ja, auch dem Obama, ja? Ich meine, diese Cable-Veröffentlichung war weitestgehend peinlich für die USA, hat aber auch für die Auseinandersetzung,
im Irak und so weiter. Äh äh durchaus ähm eine ganze Menge Sachen an die ans Licht gebracht. Ähm die hat Fälle von Folter ans Licht gebracht und eben mit diesem Coletral Mörder äh die Ermordung von Journalisten,
Durch ein Kampfhubschrauber äh veröffentlicht, ja? Das waren,
Und das kann man, denke ich, viele Jahre später oder die die sieben Jahre später sehen, wichtige politische Impulse, die dadurch gesetzt wurden, die auch, würde ich sagen,
Ein entscheidendes Korrektiv dargestellt haben.
Zu den kriegerischen Handlungen der USA und äh Debatten angezählt haben die sehr notwendig waren. Also das ist etwas Positives, was da geschehen ist,
Das aber natürlich auch ein Schaden für die USA hatte und entsprechend äh der Militärgerichtsbarkeit dann irgendwie verhandelt und verurteilt wurde und zack fünfunddreißig Jahre Haft. Äh in diesen in diesen, in dieser Haft hat ähm Chelsea Mening ähm.
Ich denke zwei Mal versucht sich das Leben zu nehmen, wenn ich das richtig mitgezählt habe äh ihre Haftbedingungen wurden äh vom Berichterstatter der Vereinten Nationen gerügt. Ähm
Und sie hatte dann noch diese ganze Situation mit ihrer ähm äh mit ihrer äh Geschlechts ähm,
Mit ihrem Geschlechtswandel, ähm die auf den so ein Militärgefängnis auch nicht unbedingt vorbereitet ist. Ähm,
ist wirklich denke ich an dieser ganzen Sache zerbrochen. Jetzt gab es dann eben ne zu okay Ende der Präsidentschaft gab es dann eben die Bewegung, die von Barack Obama forderte,
setze die Haftstrafe aus.
Und das ist auch das, was er getan hat. Er hat sie nicht begnadigt, was glaube ich, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, hieß sie, okay sofort schuldfrei, alles vorbei, sondern er hat gesagt, ich verkürze das Urteil auf,
sieben Jahre, sodass du eben am siebzehnten Mai,
in die Freiheit entlassen wirst und dann deine Haftstrafe verbüßt hast, heißt aber gleichzeitig auch, du bist weiterhin das Urteil gilt weiterhin, ne? Du bist in allen in allen dir vorgelegten Strafen schuldig,
Und ähm bist nicht ne, bist nicht frei von Sünde äh vor dem vor dem Rechtsstrafstaat.
Das ist das, was da geschehen ist und man muss trotzdem sagen, dass niemand länger in Haft war als Chelsea Mening, für für derartige Sünden oder für derartige Entschuldigung. Für derartige äh,
Vergehen für derartige Urteile. Ich denke ja auch, dass es der größere Teil der Urteile falsch war in sich,
in Begründung und Benennung falsch ähm aber äh nun mal rechtskräftig. Die bleiben auch rechtskräftig diese Verurteilung. Nur äh sie kommt jetzt halt
frei. Ähm das wurde natürlich dann so als ein großer Akt der Gnade von äh von Barack Obama gefeiert und so und dann muss natürlich trotzdem sagen, die äh diese.
Das war dennoch grundfalsch und es ist jetzt durch nicht das Barack Obama deswegen eine weiße Weste hätte. So, er hat sie hatte äh ähm eigentlich nie verurteilt werden dürfen.
Ähm,
er hat noch eine ganze Menge anderen Scheiß auf dem Capholz, den er jetzt durch diese eine äh Communitation nicht unbedingt ähm.
Alles ungeschehen macht. Ich wollte aber noch auf Adrian Lemo zurückgehen, denn Jelsey Menning wäre nie verurteilt worden, wenn Adrian Lemo äh sie nicht ans Messer geliefert hätte.
Und was äh Edwin Lemo damals getan hat, war, dass er äh also erstens, als dann diese ähm,
als dann diese Communitation ausgesprochen wurde, twitterte er irgendwie sowas wie ähm ja. Also ähm er freut sich natürlich, dass das jetzt geschehen ist, seine Handlungen damals
Also den Verrat an dieser Person hält aber nach wie vor für ähm für richtig unter den damals gegebenen Umständen,
Irremain Conference in Mytwenty Tentisision in der Time and Circustance in Wissen,
EU ist cold, war der Head to be made then and there. Also, ich stehe jetzt zu meiner, ich bin, ich stehe mit,
Ich stehe entschieden zu meiner Entscheidung zwanzig zehn, zu dieser Zeit und unter diesen Umständen war sie notwendig, sie war kalt, aber sie musste dann und dort,
getroffen werden.
Und ähm dann habe ich mir mal wieder rausgesucht, äh dot com. Hatte nämlich dann den kompletten Chatverlauf von Adrian Lemo und ähm äh damals noch Bradley Mening veröffentlicht,
wo er ganz zu Beginn sagt, Image Journalist Anneminister, you can pick ever
Modecom of Legal Protection. Also er hat ja quasi gesagt, du du kannst der jetzt kannst quasi frei wählen, ob du mit mir unter den unter dem Vorzeichen des.
Des Anvertrauens an einen Journalisten oder an einen Priester oder an einen äh ähm geistlichen Suchs,
Und unter diesem Vorzeichen bin ich bereit, mit dir zu sprechen, denn du kannst wählen, unter welchem Vorzeichen du mit mir sprichst. Und seine Antwort darauf ist.
Sie hat ja keins von beiden gewählt.
Sky, ne? Also er, er sagt quasi so, ah, er hat vertraue dich mir ruhig an. Ich bin ein geistlicher und ein Journalist und ähm.
Tues One und sie hat's aber nicht explizit gesagt äh ich werfe eine Münze ein und entscheide mich für Priester, sondern äh sie hat einfach weiter sich ihm anvertraut, weil sie ihm vertraut hat,
er hat sie an ein Messer geliefert, was äh wie es kein größeres und kein übleres in der Welt gibt, ja? Ähm,
Der läuft halt irgendwie noch rum und findet halt irgendwie völlig in Ordnung. Nun muss man dazu sagen, dass er äh prinzipiell die die ähm.
Die Prädisposition hat sehr formal zu denken und äh wenn das jetzt nun mal sein einziges
wenn das jetzt der die eine Ausrede ist, auf der das alles stützt und auch noch heute in Ordnung findet, dann muss sie eben vielleicht auch einfach gegönnt sein.
Na gut, so ist das halt.
Ein anderer, der äh interessant ist dazu ist, äh unser Freund Juria Sanchov. Der ähm nämlich schon.
Wann war das? Zweitausend im am Januar im im Moment. Im Januar.
Oder Juli? Juri klingt besser, ne?
Juri klingt besser, ne? Juria Sandschaft. Jurias Handschuh. Juria Sunshof twitterte am siebzehnten, der am zwölften Januar, also kurz vor Obamas Amtsende, ne? Also eine Woche bevor Obama äh auf jeden Fall seinen letzten Arbeitstag hat,
Twitterte er, Ilf Obama Grands Manning Clemens E. Clear and Constitutionality of the DOG Case. Also, wenn Obama.
Menning einen ähm eine Begnadigung äh ausspricht,
oder Gnade, wenn er ihr milde gibt, wenn er ihr Gnade gibt, dann wird äh Julian Assange sich an die USA ausliefern lassen, auch wenn der ganze Case den das Department of Justice gegen ihn aufgebaut hat, ganz klar äh,
nicht ähm verfassungsgemäß ist. Und als dann äh aus raus kam so okay,
Machen wir? So.
Sagte er relativ schnell. Ja nee ähm also ich habe ja gnade gesagt und jetzt ist ja hier nur eine Kürzung des Urteils. Das ist ja nicht wirklich Gnade. Also ähm da da halte ich mich jetzt also das äh näh
so die Regeln meines Spieles wurden hier nicht eingehalten.
Bitte werfen sie noch eine Mütze.
Werden sie noch eine Mütze ein und ähm also das ist schon echt geil, ja. Und ähm.
Und äh in einem weiteren Guardian-Interview,
sagt er jetzt so ja das war eigentlich nur das, warum du jetzt nur gemacht um mir das Leben schwer zu machen. Und da da merkst du auch das lässt auch tief blicken, ja? Dass jemand ernsthaft meint, dass es so, dass er sich selber nicht schämt ähm,
dass jetzt auch noch in,
Das kleine bisschen Klemens, die das kleine bisschen Gnade, was da vor recht ergangen ist, jetzt auch noch in den Dreck zu ziehen. Äh als wäre das alles nur geschehen, um ähm um um ihm das Leben schwer zu machen. Ich habe eh den Eindruck, dass der,
den Eindruck hat, dass sich vieles in der Welt nur noch um ihn dreht und äh während diese Welt sich einfach weiter dreht. Und auch das sei eben dann eben gegönnt, also dann soll er eben weiter da in der egadorianischen Botschaft sitzen.
Mensch, echt äh die alten Helden.
Edwards Norden hat keinen Gnaden bekommen. Wir haben das schon vor vor mehreren Monaten besprochen, dass Obama ja sagte, ja nee, um um meine Gnade zu bekommen, müsste er sich erst einmal ein ähm,
einem Gericht stellen, das stimmt eben nicht.
Für den für den Gnadenerlass ist es glaube ich nach Ansicht der meisten rechtsgelehrten einfach grundsätzlich nicht notwendig, der kann auch so einfach sagen ich begnadige dich. Ähm.
Aber ich glaube bei Snowden wollte er das auch einfach nicht. Ne? Also Menning ist ist, ich glaube für ihn.
Das Ding ist auch zu aufgeladen.
Für ihn ist auch einfach eine Sache, dass er sagen, dass er natürlich auch anderen gegenüber sagen kann, äh äh okay, sieben Jahre Militärhaft und äh zwei Sudizidversuche.
Kann man auch mal sagen reicht, während äh äh Snowden als fortwährender äh Kritiker die Geheimdienste.
Und unter je immer unter Freiheit gelebt haben dann natürlich eine eine krass kritischere Entscheidung ist und diese Abwägung hat er eben nicht getroffen.
Freiheit in Airquarz.
Die Freiheit, die ich meine.
Hätte nur eine ganze andere ganze Reihe anderer Leute gegeben, aber wir sind erstmal froh, dass wenigstens stellt sie mir jetzt raus ist.
Gut so viel zu den guten Nachrichten. Kommen wir zur Realität. Ähm.
Hast du, haste.
Da werden wir es jetzt aber hoffentlich nicht zu sehr mit aufhalten.
Geguckte.
Äh nee, nicht wirklich, ich.
Doch hast du die Besucherzahlen waren überragend.
Tja,
Also ich hab's äh natürlich am Rande äh so mitgenommen, aber mehr so ähm über Twitterströme und und was sonst halt noch so äh lief, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich habe dafür keine keine Kraft gehabt, also mir mir dieses Geschehen auch noch anzuschauen.
Ich habe mir die volle Dröhnung gegeben, ich habe mir das angeguckt. Ich habe mir angeschaut, wie Mike Pence eingeschworen wurde und ich habe mir angeschaut, wie Brack Obama eingeschworen wurde. Äh.
Wie äh Donald Trump eingeschworen wurde und ich habe mir vor allem seine Rede danach angeschaut und es war.
Es gab ja so, also,
Wir sind ja auch jetzt schon wieder spät dran, ist jetzt ist jetzt fünf Tage her oder vier Tage her. Ähm es gab ja so ein bisschen vielleicht Hoffnung, dass der irgendwie runterkommt, ne? Und dass er sagt, okay, ich bin jetzt ähm der mächtigste Mann dieser Erde.
Und ich werde jetzt diese Macht mit Würde.
Ausüben und äh zum Wohle des Volkes. Zum Wohl des Volkes hat er auch gesagt und hat sich da bei einem beim Batman-Bösewicht Bayen bedient. Das ist also Bahn ist der erste, der Batman wirklich schaden konnte
ja? Ist also eine DC Comicfigur. Ähm,
die auch in dem Film Bedarf Night Risis vorkommt und dort irgendwie davon ne, also irgendwie Goffem natürlich unter seine Gewalt bringt und und einer der Böses tut und dann eben sagt so
Und jetzt gebe ich die Macht zurück an euch. Die Menschen to you, the people und,
Trump hat den Wortgleich betonungsgleich in dieser Rede zitiert, ne.
Das ist schon echt krass, euer Blick kommen die auf sowas. Machen sie das absichtlich.
Der Trump oder dass.
Meine ist ja jetzt also erstens glaubst du, dass der Trab seine Rede selber geschrieben hat, weil dauert es.
Ich glaube der hat die nicht abgelesen und ähm ich habe, also ich weiß es nicht genau, habe ich nicht. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass er die auswendig gelernt hat. Ich glaube, ernsthaft hat der einfach gesagt hat.
Teleprompter benutzt hat.
Fuck it will do it life. Oder da hat ein Telefonband, das kann auch sein, ja.
Es kann auf, also ich weiß es nicht, aber.
Am Ende war's ziemlich genau das, äh.
Die Frage von die Frage, wenn du so eine Rede hältst, ja, dann kannst du dann kannst du dich da hinstellen.
Und kannst versuchen, eine Rede zu halten, hinter der alle stehen, die dann natürlich ein bisschen typisches Wischiwaschi ist, aber eine Rede, wo du alle mitnimmst,
Und wo du irgendwie eine positive Zukunftsvision entfaltest, ja? Das kannst du machen, da würde ich auch grundsätzlich zu raten. Du kannst aber natürlich auch hingehen und erstmal.
Du in deiner Rolle als Präsidentenberater.
Ich in meiner Rolle als Präsidentenberater, würde sagen, pass auf, versuche eine historische Rede zu halten.
Versuche eine Rede zu halten, die ähm die viele hinter dir vereint und ähm.
Versuche nicht erstmal die Hälfte der anwesenden Leute,
Fundamental zu beleidigen und zu beschimpfen. Und was er quasi, also er redet ja über die zu lange, war Amerika in den Zwängen von von den,
Eliten Washingtons äh die sich und jetzt befreit er die jetzt er befreit Amerika und jetzt ist es America First, jetzt ist es America First. Also es war einfach ein,
Eine unnötige.
Schimpftirade. Ja? Die er da abgelassen hat. Und dazu würde hätte ich ihm grundsätzlich einfach nicht geraten, weil es halt einfach ähm.
Zeigt, dass er nicht.
Also das wird immer noch nötig hat, ne? Er zeigt einfach nur Junge, du hast es immer noch nötig, andere zu beschimpfen. Und das sollte dir irgendwann in deinem Leben.
Im Moment des größten Triumphes äh.
Spätestens dann wenn du Präsident wirst, solltest du so ein bisschen was entwickeln wie äh.
Über dich selber hinwegblicken können und über deine eigenen Kränkungen hinweg zu blicken
Und äh sowas wie ein Blick nach vorne zu entwickeln. Und wenn du es in in einer solchen Situation, in deiner wichtigsten Rede am Ende, ja, also du wirst jetzt noch irgendwie
Wenn du Glück hast, vier, wenn du Pech hast, nee, wenn du Glück hast, acht. Wenn du Pech hast, keine äh State of the Union sprechen, das wäre auch noch eine ähnlich wichtige Rede,
Aber du wirst keine wichtigeren Reden mehr als Präsident halten und keine viel beachteteren Reden mehr. Und wenn dir da nichts anderes einfällt als Platt.
Gesamte politische System zu beschimpfen,
Dann ist das ähm tragisch. Dann ist das tragisch, weil es zeigt, dass du nach wie vor.
Nichts besseres hast als den Gegner runterzumachen. Und deswegen hätte ich ihm davon abgeraten eine solche Rede zu halten.
Ja, ich meine, das das kann man jetzt glaube ich schließen das Kapitel, dieser Typ äh wird kein Ende finden,
So und das hat sich ja dann auch gleich einen Tag später äh äh gezeigt, seine erste Rede hat er wenn Drei vor der CIA äh gehalten.
Einen Moment, es gibt noch, es, ich würde noch zu der einen Punkt sein, den wir echt ansprechen müssen.
Es kursierten dann relativ früh Bilder, also der diese Innogration findet eben statt vor dem Capitol in und das Capitol blickt auf den Park The National Mall. Das ist dieser also dieser viel bekannte,
Platz, an dem dann irgendwie auch so die wichtigen US-Reden stattfinden. Ähm ich meine eigentlich, dass man Lufer King da auch die Rede gehalten hat, oder? Ähm.
Oder? Ähm weiß ich es nicht.
Weiß ich auch nicht. Der hat ein bisschen auch jetzt kurz googeln.
Mache ich schon. Ja, eine vor dem Linken Mimorial.
Ja, das ist National Mor,
Ne? Also es ist so, da sind die gesamte Pracht der amerikanischen Demokratie in einen Park und riesige Figuren gegossen. Das ist The National Mall
Ja, also einfach so. Äh das ist halt Washington. Wenn du ein Bild von Washington siehst, mit dem Park, dann ist das dieser Park, das ist irgendwie deren Heiligen, der ein heilige Rasen, ne?
Und äh wenn da so eine eine Auguration stattfindet, dann ist natürlich, dann kommen da natürlich viele Leute hin. Und da gibt's eine Web eine Webcam, die das dieses Gelände überblickt. Und ähm,
Dann gab's ein Bild von Obamas in Auguration, wo einfach du,
statt Boten nur Menschen siehst und Trumps in Auguration wurde an vielen Flächen Bodensees,
Und zwar sehr gut bodensiehst, weil die irgendwelche weißen Folien ausgelegt haben, auf denen eben keiner stand. Und ähm es war also relativ schnell klar, dass diese Inauguration bei weitem nicht von so vielen Menschen besucht wurde, wie die von Obama,
Was sich auch mit verschiedenen Faktoren erklären lässt, ja? Also äh,
Washington DC ist kein ähm ist nicht einfach ist einfach nicht der Kern von Obamas äh ähm Wählerschaft, ja? Der wurde,
äh von Trump sorry. Von von Trumps Wähler, das heißt, wenn da Trump-Supporter hinwollten, mussten die von weiter her anreisen.
Und ähm da waren halt nicht so viele.
Das ist das mag dem Trump jetzt missfallen. Also das ist aber einfach mal ein Fakt. Und dieser Fakt wurde berichtet.
Da gab's halt, ne, diese Fotos wurden, die waren ja von der Webcam des US Martial Service oder Park and Morial Service, der also diesen
diesen der diese National Moll pflegt, von dem auch diese Webcam da ist und da wurde halt dieser Vergleich gezeigt und war einfach mal ein nicht,
zu diskutieren der Fakt, dass da weniger Menschen waren. Da kann man sich jetzt noch lange Gedanken darüber machen, warum das so war.
Vielleicht gab's auch höhere Sicherheitsvorkehrungen und die waren alle
in Washington und konnten nicht in den in den Sicherheitsbereich oder oder oder, aber da waren nun mal keine Menschen. Und andere Bilder von von
Pens zeigen auch wie ihr denn nachher die Straßen rumgeht und da überall irgendwelche Gitterabsperrungen sind und da ist auch keiner. Da war einfach keiner. Da sind es war einfach leer,
Und äh er hat ja auch diese Proville-Ratings sind hier irgendwie die niedrigsten hier, ein US-Präsident. Äh hatte, also der Mann hat halt gerade seine Unterstützung verloren.
Und das wurde berichtet und dann kam es zu der ersten ähm zu der ersten Pressekonferenz seines neuen.
Pressesprechers. Und der hat also, der macht also da die die Presse erstmal zur Sau.
Und sagt, das war die bestbesuchte Inauguration in der Geschichte der Vereinigten Staaten. Punkt.
Es sah aus wie eineinhalb Millionen.
Und jeder, der was anderes sagt, kriegt hier Probleme, da könnte er von ausgehen. Nimmt keine Fragen an.
Nur so eine Tirade, ne.
Und hat fertig.
Wird fertig, genau.
Sagt also der ganze Platz war voll, als äh äh Trump, den Amtszeit leistete, das ist einfach nicht richtig,
Ähm und dann sagte er, es wurden Bodenplatten benutzt, um den Rasen zu schützen, so wurden leere Plätze stärker sichtbar als in den letzten Jahren. Diese Bodenplatten, wie gesagt, waren weiß, andere haben halt gesagt, ähm,
andere haben halt gesagt, vielleicht waren das auch einfach alles Kuckucks, Klanhänger und deswegen sah das so weiß aus. Ähm dann gibt's irgendwie eine schöne ähm,
Gibt es schöne Zahlen, äh die die Transportbehörde der USA immer veröffentlicht. Nämlich wie viele Menschen,
in
Washington DC unterwegs waren. Wir haben ja, gibt's ja Statistiken, sind ja ist ja ein technisches System. Und die sagen halt, wie viele, wie viele ähm Leute, die Matro benutzt haben. Und sagen halt, naja, bei Obama zwanzig dreizehn waren es dreihundertundsiebzehntausend,
Und jetzt sagt der äh dieser Pressesprecher von Trump. Ja, bei uns waren's vierhundertzwanzigtausend. Stimmt aber nicht, waren nur hundertdreiundneunzig. Also ihr geht einfach hin und lügt, ja.
So, die Zahl war äh war schon richtig, die bezog sich allerdings auf den ganzen Tag.
Ja genau und die die tatsächlichen Zahlen sind irgendwie bis.
Ist nicht falsch, ja? Sind keine falschen Fakten. Sie sind nur anders arrangiert.
Und das war ja dann auch der Punkt. Also dann wurde die äh man wie heißt die Mariamarian Call Conway, jetzt glaube ich ausgesprochen? Ähm.
Die dann damit äh konfrontiert wurde und gesagt wurde, ey, also sag mal ganz ehrlich, wie ist es jetzt zu verstehen, dass dieser Typ ganz offenkundig,
vor die in seiner ersten Pressekonferenz dahin tritt mehrere Callians, Entschuldigung, Callian komme, äh Trump-Beraterin, ganz offen, kundige Lügen vertritt.
Keine Fragen annimmt, ist das jetzt irgendwie das Neue? Äh ist das die neue, die neue Beziehung zur Presse, die ihr da auf äh die der jetzt irgendwie vorführen wollt? Und sie sagt dann eben.
Ja, haltet mal die Luft an, so, das ist ja alles gar nicht so wild. Also, ne,
was hier in Wirklichkeit passiert ist ist das und der Pressesprecher alternative Fakten präsentiert hat.
Und das spätestens das war der Moment, wo wo ich, muss ich echt sagen, Tim, wo ich echt Schiss bekommen habe.
Weil diese Drogen, die der da ausgesprochen hat. Trump ist ja nachher auch vor die CIA getreten, hat gesagt, er hat einen Krieg mit den Medien.
Ähm ne, also wir haben jetzt hier irgendwie diesen US-Präsidenten da, der falsch, also der Unwahrheiten als alternativen Fakten vertreten lässt, der davon redet, dass er einen Krieg mit den Medien führen würde.
Und eine Beraterin, die sagt, ja, ey, das sind alternative Fakten. Und gleichzeitig durch seinen Sprecher diese Medienvertreter bedrohen lässt.
Ja, aber ich würde gerne noch ein bisschen darüber reden, wie fucking gefährlich das ist.
Ja, es geht ja noch weiter. Ich meine, diese ist ja auch wirklich äh ich meine, die ist ja jetzt nichts Neues, also Wahrheiten verdrehen, es sieht nun mal äh ist hier einfach mal spitze, ja? Also ich meine äh hast du schon vorher schon mal Interviews von je gesehen?
Da rollen sich die Fußnägel hoch, also die, die liegt einfach schon immer wie gedruckt und und kann die ganze Zeit dabei auch noch irgendwie komisches Botox-Lächeln da durchziehen,
Sie meinte ja dann auch noch äh kurze Zeit später. Es wäre ja auch ganz angemessen, ähm wenn Trump seine eigene Geheimdienst-Community installieren äh,
würde, weil es wäre ja,
Regierung würde ja bevorzugen ähm Geheimdienstler zu haben, die dem Riss dem Präsidenten mehrere Aspekte entgegenbringen.
Also machen wir uns nichts vor. Wir haben's hier nicht mit irgendeinem.
TV-Darsteller, der sich einfach nur geil findet,
zu tun und jetzt wird er in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten in aller Lächerlichkeit vor sich hinscheitern, sondern wir haben's ja ein äh ein mit einem Anführer zu tun
eine extrem gefährlichen Bande von Leuten, die einfach dabei sind, die Grundfesten auf den äh,
die USA gebaut ist, die schon genug zu kritisieren, äh übrig ließ in letzter Zeit das nochmal komplett in eine Richtung zu drehen, die wir gemeinhin einfach als Faschismus kennen. Das ist so quasi so Erdogan, Teil zwei.
Und da läuft's hin. Oh, und die eigentliche Frage ist, kann,
Die USA als Gesellschaft dem was Nennenswertes entgegensetzen. So, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher.
Das Problem ist, dass sie also worauf diese Taktik absieht, also warum das auch so warum also wie viele Leute da waren, ist doch fucking egal. Der wird in Zukunft eine ganze Menge politisch entscheidende ähm Dinge tun.
Ja, aber wenn man sich über solche Sachen unterhält, dann wird darüber halt geredet. Ich meine, sogar du redest ja darüber.
Ja, ich, ja, aber genau, ich rede aus einem bestimmten Grund drüber. Und dieser Grund ist, dass es eine völlig völlig scheißegal ist,
wie viele Leute bei dieser innere Orguation waren. Und der fängt schon darüber, also es ist erstens ein ein Zeichen des,
Wirklich einfach das sehr, sehr tief verwurzelten Narzissmus von Donald Trump. Der hatte sich
immer noch durch so einen Mist überhaupt aus der Ruhe bringen lässt, ja? Sogar seinen Pressesprecher wütend äh die Medien bedrohen lässt. Das ist einfach ne, also so eine so eine Blöße kannst du ja eigentlich gar nicht geben
ne? Da musst du schon echt eine Meise für haben, aber okay. Ähm,
Das ist der eine Punkt. Der andere ist, wenn du über so eine tatsächlich ziemlich irrelevante Geschichte äh in,
Die Medien schon bedrohst, dann setzt du von vornherein einen ganz klaren Ton. Und dieser Ton ist, Freunde, es gibt hier, ihr könnt jetzt mit uns.
Oder ihr könnt ohne uns. Und wir werden in Zukunft noch so viel Scheiße an Lügen über euch gießen,
dass ihr nicht die Zeit haben werdet, das alles zu widerlegen.
Hm
Und selbst wenn ihr euch die Zeit nehmt, wird euch auf mittelbare Zeit keiner mehr dabei zuhören. Weil.
Die Leute werden müde werden. Wir geben hier ab jetzt den Ton an und ihr könnt entweder mitspielen.
Und könnt den Scheiß, den wir labern, veröffentlichen und der äh die fröhliche äh die fröhliche Kunde des Sonnengotts in die Welt tragen oder.
Ihr kriegt hier einfach kein Platz mehr am Tisch.
Es kippt, wir sind jetzt die Mächtigsten und ihr habt keine Schnitte mehr gegen uns. Und das ist wir haben genug,
Beispiele in dieser Welt wo und du hast hier gerade schon genannt, wo alleinige Herrscher mit offenkundigen Lügen und Unwahrheiten.
Einfach ein Framework setzen, indem die Gesellschaft funktioniert und zu funktionieren hat,
Und es ist nicht das erste Mal, dass Menschen in einer im Prinzip, sage ich mal, fundamentalen Lüge leben.
Und das über ein paar Jahre lang gut geht. Und das ist das, was uns hier ähm mit dieser Trump-Geschichte in V steht.
Und das finde ich das ist der Grund, warum ich da richtig Schiss bekommen habe,
Weil ich auch selber nicht genau weiß äh wie man dieser Sache, wie man dieser Sache her wird und da ist diese Entfernung von von Ratio und äh und Verstand und irgendwie evidenzbasierter Politik und allem, was uns,
jemals irgendwo liebgewonnen äh lieb war, ist genau da, wo eine Regierung hingeht und sagt, pass auf, Freunde. Ab jetzt gehen wir hier den Ton an,
Und wenn ihr den nicht mittanzt, den den Tango, den wir hier vorgehen, dann wird das eben unangenehm.
Und das schon wegen den Besuchern bei der dieser Inauguration zu eskalieren, ist einfach mal eine Kampfansage.
Ja
Und das ist.
Ja und man sieht halt äh äh als nächstes nimmt er sich irgendwie die Geheimdienste äh vor, ja. Ich meine, das ist also wirklich so reudig.
Mitbekommen, dass er dann bei dieser seine nächste Rede bei der CIA äh gehalten hat,
und dann ist ihnen irgendwie auch nochmal so ein richtiger Lapsus äh passiert, weil offensichtlich hat,
sein Team, was wahrscheinlich genauso orientierungslos ist in diesem ganzen politischen Apparat, den sie da jetzt frisch betreten haben wie er selber, ja? Haben dann irgendwie so eine,
Mimorial Wall, bei der CIA äh ausgesucht, wo er dann seine Rede gehalten hat und dann irgendwie den CIA-Mitarbeitern irgendwie ausführlich erklärt hat, wie oft er doch schon, wie geil, dass er derjenige wäre, der am meisten irgendwie bei Time, Magazine aufm Titel war,
Auch wieder nicht stimmt.
Zweitens sieht sie ja, ey, echt nicht beeindruckend.
Weißt du wer am meisten auf Time Titel war? Nixen. Ja, also auch warum man auf einem Time Titel landet und so weiter. Vollkommen egal.
Aber das Absurde war dieser Raum und diese Mimorie äh das ist so ein interner,
Superheiliger Gedenktafel für Gefallene CIA äh Leute, wo normalerweise sowieso
fast nie überhaupt irgendwelche Veranstaltungen öffentlich stattfinden, schon gar nicht unter Beteiligung von Präsidenten und die zweimal, wo George Bush und Obama da waren, haben die sich natürlich ausführlich und äh mit maximalem Bres,
irgendwie dann auch diesem Thema der gefallenen Soldaten äh gewidmet, wovon Trump wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal irgendwas wusste und es natürlich dementsprechend auch in seiner Rede nicht untergebracht hat,
Stattdessen halt die ganze Zeit dann wieder so ein Breging äh Content da gestartet hat auf die Medien eingehauen hat und
Pipapo und den CA Leuten irgendwas äh um die um die Ohren geschmiert hat. Wie wichtig sie doch angeblich seien,
aber auch noch in diese Andenkensraum auch noch irgendwie vierzig Laköre mitgebracht, die die ganze Zeit irgendwie gejubelt haben. Also.
Den musste der ja was bieten.
Das Ding ist.
Klar, die haben eine Agenda, ich denke auch, dass die äh eine ganze Menge wirklich kluger Hardliner in der zweiten und dritten Reihe haben, die diesen Weg jetzt irgendwie steuern und Trump ist einfach hier Vehikel.
Im erzählen sie hier einfach, du bist jetzt hier unser Sonnengott und und äh du kannst das hier irgendwie alles genießen und das und das und das und die Dinge, wo es irgendwie hingeht, so, also der, dem haben sie den Film auch schon gezeigt, aber wahrscheinlich einen anderen als äh als der anderen Präsidenten bisher,
und ähm fahren das jetzt irgendwie so durch. Es kann aber auch sein, um mal so ein Fünkchen Hoffnung noch in diese Nummer noch mit reinzubringen. Es kann sein.
Dass ihr einfach bei diesem gewachsenen Establishment, das ist ja auch nie ohne, ja? Und das ist ja auch in den Republikanern auch drin. Äh dass sie sich da schon auch irgendwann mal eine eine.
Eine blutige Nase holen in einem Maße, wo es für sie dann eben nicht so einfach weitergeht. Ne, wir werden ja gleich noch zwei, drei andere äh Bereiche hier entfalten, wo schon die ersten,
Ja, Krisen sich äh für diese Regierung auch abzeichnen.
Also vielleicht um das noch ein bisschen äh äh wenn du da bei diesen Geheimdiensten antrittst und so, es gibt etwas ähm,
Da gibt's die, da haben wir ja auch, glaube ich, immer empfohlen, hat vor ein paar Jahren der äh Arthur Andreas Lena einen äh einen Vortrag drüber gehalten,
tiefe Staat, ja? Ähm und zwar.
Ich versuche das mal kurz zusammenzufassen. Es gibt natürlich in so einem in seinem Staat eine ganze Menge Leute.
Die in signifikanten Machtpositionen sind und die sich durch eine Wahl auch nicht ändern.
Also sowas wie das mag sein, dass der, dass der Geheimdienstchef mal das ein oder andere Mal abgesetzt und geändert wird oder so, aber die ganze, die Macht der Geheimdienste sitzt halt
Bei den Geheimdiensten und sitzt auch da sitzt irgendwie auch darin wieder jeder einzelne Agent und jeder einzelne Abteilungsleiter seine Arbeit tut,
Und die lassen sich nicht unbedingt jeden Tag davon umstehen, weil gerade mal jemand anders was Neues gewählt hat. Die haben zentrale,
Ziele vor Augen, die haben zentrale Feinde vor Augen und entsprechend arbeiten die.
Das dient vollkommen egal, wer unter ihnen Präsident ist.
Das ist denen völlig egal, wer unter ihm Präsident ist. Das gleiche hast du in hier in vielen anderen Behörden natürlich auch.
Ähm das hast du, es gibt zum Beispiel die, die äh die Theorie, ähm dass Obama Care unter anderem deshalb so einen schlechten Start hatte,
weil das ganz einfach in den Getrieben, in die es reingegeben wurde.
Durch, wir machen Dienst nach Vorschrift, ausreichend sabotiert werden konnte. Ne, also dieser wiederholte, desaströse Start, den äh den den Obama-Care hatte, der wird gerne dem zugeschrieben, dass quasi der tiefe Start,
da ganz einfach mal so, ne? Die, die Muskeln hat spielen lassen. Und es kann natürlich sehr gut sein, dass der,
dass der Obama, äh der, der Trump, warum lerne ich denn nur wahr? Ich weiß es auch nicht, vielleicht weil ich ihn halt, weil ich vielleicht guckt's mir einfach.
Du willst ein, du willst deinen Barock zurückhaben.
Vielleicht kochst du ja einfach nicht über die Lippen. Dass er sich daran ähm dass er sich daran noch die Zähne ausbeißt. Ähm umso.
Krasser wird natürlich auch für dieser A France gesehen. Also ich glaube, dass dem relativ klar ist, dass der diesen tiefen Start äh richtig fett einen vor dem Bug geben muss. Und zwar direkt zu Beginn. Da musst du es richtig eine Nacht der langen Messer geben,
Da muss es Blut in den Straßen geben.
Weil er weiß, die muss er jetzt auf Zack bringen. Weil wenn er das nicht macht, dann hat er da äh nicht mehr lange Zeit für,
Und ähm das könnte halt sein, dass das äh also von einigen wird es eben auch als so ein Affen gegen genau das äh äh gegen dieses Vorgehen
oder gegen diese Strukturen gesehen, dass er genau da bei der CIA sich hinstellt und den auf ihr auf ihre heiligste Statue pisst,
sich noch vierzig vierzig Jubel Persa damit hinbringen, ja? Einfach nur mal zu demonstrieren, guckt mal Freunde, damit komme ich durch.
Und das ist wenn der Typ irgendeine Strategie hat, dann ist das gerade die Strategie, die äh die da durchgezogen wird.
Ja, der neue Pinkelprinz teilt aus.
Tja, aber dann wollen wir uns mal äh anschauen. Er hat ja dann auch direkt was getan, ja? Also.
Der hat tatsächlich ne, es gab ja viele, die immer sagten, ja äh jetzt wollen wir erstmal schauen ähm.
Was denn Trump macht, ne? Wollen wir ihn ja an seinen Taten bewerten und äh nicht jetzt schon Sorge davor schüren, äh was dieser Mensch alle in welcher Position dieser Mensch ist. Äh wollen wir ihm mal nicht äh wollen wir ihn mal nicht verurteilen, bevor er etwas getan hat,
Vor allem so ist.
Lass ihn doch erstmal machen, ne? Insbesondere so intellektuelle haben das dann viel gemacht, ne? Also Geisteswissenschaftler, die sagen so, da kann man ihnen jetzt nicht vorher äh verurteilen und so. Und da hat der Obama sich auch äh der Trump sich auch mal erkühte,
Da hat der Trump sich dann auch gesagt so.
Ich sage jetzt immer, eh, wenn dir das passiert.
Da hat Trumps nicht gedacht, hast du Recht? Den Geisteswissen schafft man den Intellektuellen, die der Digitiert vielleicht über Monate und Jahre beschwichtigt haben, was ihr aufgebaut habe. Denen muss ich eigentlich auch noch kurz zeigen, ab wann es ernst wird
Ich streiche den erstmal äh äh hundertvierundachtzig Millionen staatliche Förderung für die Geisteswissenschaften. Bin ich mal gespannt ähm
wie die Geisteswissenschaftler jetzt damit umgehen werden, ähm muss man natürlich sagen, äh in den USA sind Universitäten ja eh schon sehr viel mehr äh privat geführt. Das heißt, der hat jetzt nicht die Geisteswissenschaften abgeschafft
Aber sowas wie hundertvierundachtzig äh hundertvierundachtzig Millionen äh für ein ähm.
Nur nur die, die noch nicht einer kapitalistischen Nadel hängen.
Ist natürlich gerade für,
Für die Geisteswissenschaften ein schwerer Schlag, weil mit den Forschungsgegenständen, denen sich die Geistesgeistes gegen äh die Geisteswissenschaften so zuwenden. Äh die sind ja auch häufig fernab von jeglicher ähm,
kapitalistischer, wenn nicht sogar gesellschaftlicher äh Wertschöpfung und ähm da muss man sicherheitsgeisteswissenschaftler natürlich.
Auch jetzt mal ähm,
dem America First Burgen bürgen und äh der der harten Tatsache ins Auge sehen. Dass das, was man erforscht, eben fernab von wirtschaftlichen Interessen stattfindet und dem müssen die sich jetzt natürlich auch beugen. Bitter.
Ist doch bemerkenswert, was so ein Präsident in USA alles mal so eben beschließen kann, ne.
Ja, TTIP kündigen, kann man auch mal Tschuldigung, TP kündigen,
Hat er auch gesagt, also TVP eigentlich, also das Trans Transpacific Partnership, ein ähm,
Ein Freihandelsabkommen in Richtung,
in Richtung ähm also eigentlich prinz primär Richtung
Japan eigentlich, ne? Aber auch mit so also eine das eine Vereinigung betrifft.
Ich.
TP ist halt eine Malaysia, Australien, Neuseeland, auch Japan äh mit dem Boot, noch ein paar andere Länder. Äh vor allem ist halt ein Land nicht dabei, nämlich China.
Ja, aber da sollten auch Australien, Brunai und Japan zugehören. Also ein ach hast du gesagt.
Australien, Japan und andere.
Ach so, weil du das sagte.
Hatte ich jetzt nicht im Kopf.
Ich auch nicht, aber ein ein Freihandelsabkommen, äh dass also den Pazifikraum umfassen sollte und ähm.
Dort für eigentlich knapp dreizehn Komma fünf Prozent der globalen Wirtschaftsleistung betreffen sollte,
Und ein Gegengewicht zu China darstellen sollte.
Das hat äh und deswegen war China nicht dabei, ja? Und Trump ist jetzt hingegangen und hat gesagt, okay äh,
machen wir nicht. Ist zwar schon, ist zwar die Vereinbarung ist getroffen, dieses freie Netzabkommen ist besiegelt. Es muss aber jetzt von den Mitgliedsstaaten noch ratifiziert werden, das machen wir jetzt nicht.
Japan hat's schon ratifiziert. Muss ich das mal vorstellen? Jetzt haben die da sieben Jahre lang dran ausgehandelt. Und jetzt kommt der Trump und sagt äh.
Ja jetzt äh.
Ich freue mich vor allem, was den da reitet. Also ich meine, das ist doch eigentlich für die USA ein Riesenerfolg gewesen.
Das ist also ich kann leider, also ähm.
Ich habe zu wenig Wissen über den Inhalt und die Bedeutung von TPP. Äh um jetzt zu sagen, ob das jetzt eine was gutes oder was Schlechtes war. Ich würde aber mittelfristig schätzen, dass das.
Keine also da die USA da die das Interesse äh verfolgt haben, China ein Gegengewicht äh entgegenzusetzen. Und das quasi Anti-China,
Wirtschaftsverbündung war. Halte ich das für mittelfristig nicht unbedingt Interesse im Interesse der USA, was er da jetzt getan hat.
Ja, zum Beispiel ist Australier auch schon angekündigt, hat na ja Gott, also wir können ja TPP auch ohne die USA machen, wir bräuchten aber noch einen anderen starken Handelspartner. Wie wär's denn mit China,
Also äh äh also das ist wirklich sehr interessant. Ich meine, wir hatten ja hier auch schon mal über ähm äh TTIP gesprochen oder was CETA? Nein, wir haben über T-Tipp gesprochen,
mit ähm Tascha und ich bin da.
Auch wenn ich so richtig so sicher, wie man das insgesamt alles bewerten soll, aber die Allianzen sind wirklich obskur. Ja, also wer war auch noch gegen TPI.
Bonnie Sanders, ja.
Stimmt, der hat ja gesagt, das finde er sehr gut. Ich glaube, er müsste kurz sagen, also warum ich da nicht so genau rein will. Ich kenne, ich habe mich mit diesem Abkommen nicht zentral auseinander.
Auch nicht. Mich verwirrt das auch noch alles sehr.
Also ob das jetzt.
Sieht aber jetzt auf jeden Fall nicht so aus.
Unserer Sicht etwas positives oder Negatives ist, weiß ich nicht,
Ich glaube aber vorher sagen zu können, dass das für die USA und deren wirtschaftliches Interesse mittelfristig nicht positiv ist, was er da gemacht hat. Ähm,
Kann aber auch sein, dass ich mich da täusche. Interessant ist einfach nur, dass das sollte quasi so. Wird gemeinhin als Obamas Erbe äh gesehen,
Und das hat er jetzt äh.
Einfach nur deshalb weghauen.
Vielleicht will das auch nur deshalb weghauen.
Da sollten wir uns vielleicht mal mit jemandem unterhalten, der davon was versteht.
Da werden wir uns mal jemanden zu einladen, ähm der der sich damit genauer auseinandergesetzt hat. Interessant ist es aber, dass es eine enorm weitreichende Sache ist, ne. Kann halt auch was Positives sein. Ich bin mal gespannt. Ähm.
Kann auch sein, dass es nächste Woche ja auch schon wieder anders ist.
Kann auch sein, dass sie sich nächste Woche anders über dich. Das ist ja das Risiko haben wir ohnehin. Ähm,
Dann hat er gesagt, okay, hier ähm äh ich habe mich jetzt ich habe mich entschieden, ich bin jetzt Pro Life,
Mit anderen Worten, ich bin jetzt Abtreibungsgegner und hat ähm relativ weitreichende ähm Mittelstreichung für Abtreibungsanbieter vorgenommen.
Es geht da vor allem um dieses, wie heißt das nochmal?
Plent, die.
Plant Parent Hood genau. Mhm.
Elternschaft, ja?
Wobei man dazu sagen muss, dass halt äh diese Organisation da ist, dieser Bereich Abtreibungsberatung ein sehr, sehr, sehr kleiner Teil, das heißt, da wird noch sehr viel mehr ähm,
wieder gemacht als nur dieser Bereich. Das ist halt ganz klar, einfach ein Geschenk an die harte Rechte, ne? Bei den Republikanern.
Mhm. Aber auch nicht unbedingt was besonders positives oder progressiv ist, ne? Also.
Kann man jetzt nicht sagen, aber das war, davon war jetzt auch nicht auszugehen.
Ja
Im Bereich des Cybers hat er aber natürlich schon gesagt äh ähm er will jetzt Cyberkrieg haben, ne? Da kommen wir ein bisschen näher in unseren Themenbereich wieder.
Ähm also ähm Cyberkrieg findet er dann doch erstmal äh eine ganz, ganz spannende Geschichte und äh da will er jetzt irgendwie ähm ordentlich äh rumsibern.
Ne? Also in der in der in der in der Außen, in der Zusammenfassung seiner außenpolitischen Maßnahmen hat er hervorgehoben, äh dass er also ähm,
den Kampf gegen den IS äh mit höchster Priorität führen möchte und ähm Cyber äh Kriegsführung ähm.
Als adäquates Mittel sieht, äh deren Rekrutierung ähm zu verhindern und deren Propaganda,
äh etwas entgegenzusetzen.
Was natürlich jetzt sehr interessant, dass im Prinzip hier das erste Mal wirklich äh,
klar gesagt wird, ähm man kann das hier als man kann es nicht nur theoretisch für Gegenangriffe benutzen, sondern auch für Angriffe,
Ja, also im Prinzip ist ja hier von Krieg die Rede und ähm Angriff,
und ja da scheint ihnen überhaupt nicht zu äh jucken, dass man da einfach was machen kann. Das ist natürlich jetzt besonders schlechte Nachrichten für.
Bereiche wie die amerikanische Wirtschaft, weil wir hier schon mehrfach und oft beschworen, auch von dir, auf zahlreichen Kanälen,
heißt das natürlich im Prinzip, dass man gegenüber Sicherheitslücken, die,
Position bezieht mit schön, wenn's welche gibt, dann kann man die auch ausnutzen, bloß nicht äh dafür sorgen, dass sich hier alle besser davor schützen können und dementsprechend wird es auch seine negativen Auswirkungen haben.
Ja. Also da können wir uns, äh, da werden wir uns noch länger mit auseinandersetzen mit äh Trump und dem Cyber. Ähm,
Dann hat er ähm gesagt, ach ja hier ähm,
FCC auch bei uns schon längere Zeit Thema gewesen, ne? Die Federal Communications Comic, wenn ich das jetzt richtig spontan aufm ähm.
Äh zitiere, ähm die Regulationsbehörde, die äh sich immer wieder äh versucht, äh angestrengt hat in den USA, ne, Netzneutralitätsregulationen
hervorzubringen und durchzusetzen. Die kriegt jetzt einen neuen Chef
Und das ist ähm der ist also jetzt der neue äh Scherman dieser Commission und ähm der war einer der stärksten Kritiker,
der ähm der Netzneutralitätsbemühungen, der demokratischen,
dem demokratischen Regentschaft. Das heißt Netzneutralität
äh geht, wird es jetzt auch in absehbarer Zeit in den USA wieder an den Kragen gehen äh mit einer äh wahrscheinlich äh hundert Grad äh hundertachtzig Grad Wende
in der FCC.
Tja, weil kann ja nicht sein, dass äh.
Man da nicht alle in Geiselhaft nehmen kann, so wo man doch äh für einzelne Konzerne viel Geld bekommen kann, ja,
Damit kauft man sich natürlich dann quasi auch genau diese Managerabteilungen, die der Meinung sind, sie würden ja eh noch nicht genug Geld verdienen,
Was sicherlich auch der Hauptgrund dahinter ist, weil auch das hat natürlich nichts mit,
irgendeiner Verbesserung der Gesamtsituation der digitalen Wirtschaft zu tun. Ganz im Gegenteil.
Das finde ich nochmal, das finde ich nochmal wichtig, diese, also was wir jetzt hier schon irgendwie als als Grand ne, also was der die Leute, die da jetzt am Ende an den Hebeln sitzen, ne, die werden urkapitalistische.
Uhr äh also.
Die soziale.
Antisoziale äh Prinzipien vertreten,
Ähm das Einzige, was da jetzt, was da jetzt zukommt, ist ein ein Protektionismus, ein wirtschaftlicher Wirtschaftsprotektionismus, der also sagt, okay, wir versuchen uns als Land wieder mehr zu konsolidieren,
wir versuchen Arbeitsplätze in diesem Land aufzubauen und im internationalen Handel
drohen wir primär jetzt einfach mal mit Strafzöllen. Und durch diese Strafzölle versuchen wir andere also Industrie sowohl national als auch internationale dazu zu bringen,
wieder hier zu produzieren. Sowas kann man machen. Das geht in der Regel allerdings nicht allzu lange gut,
Ja, also so die äh die Staaten, die das machen müssen dann schon irgendwie so irgendwann chinesisches Ausmaß haben.
Aber auch China lebt davon, dass sie hauptsächlich einfach Weltmarkt äh Exporteur sind in allen möglichen Sachen. Also ich will jetzt nicht, ich bin jetzt hier kein Wirtschaftspolitikexperte, was mir ein bisschen Sorge macht, ist dieses dieses Spielchen, was Trump jetzt macht
Der der pickt sich im Prinzip willkürlich Unternehmen raus.
Und prügelt die auf sein Spiel, nämlich zu sagen, Katastrophe, die kriegen Strafzölle, die machen wir fertig.
Und dann sagen diese, dann zwei Tage später wird bekanntgegeben, dass die jetzt sich committed haben irgendwie in USA Jobs aufzubauen.
Ob diese Jobs am Ende stattfinden oder nicht? Das steht langfristig eh nochmal auf einem ganz anderen Blatt.
Aber das ist im Moment seine seine Regentschaft der Angst in in sage ich mal in der internationalen in den internationalen Handelsbeziehungen, dass sich irgendein rauspickt und sagt, hier, der ist als nächstes dran. Fünfunddreißig Prozent,
Strafzoll, fertig, ne?
Obwohl Daimler oder sowas irgendwie seit seit Jahren massiv in den USA Produktionskapazitäten aufgebaut,
BMW. Ähm also auch so fernab von Fakten, ja? Und äh die Frage ist, wie lange die Unternehmen dieses Spiel mitspielen, weil es eigentlich ein lustiger, ein lustiger Spaß ähm.
Sich von den Unternehmen diese mehr oder weniger lehren oder vielleicht auch mal nicht lehren versprechen,
geben zu lassen, weil die jedes Mal, wenn das Unternehmen dann dem Druck,
nachgibt und sagt, ja ja natürlich, wir wir machen auch America First jetzt, ne? Wir verlagern keine keine Arbeitsplätze ins Ausland. Wird das als ein Erfolg äh Erfolg der Staaten hat Donald Trumps äh interpretiert.
Ja, aber das kostet ihn natürlich auch, ne?
Was kostet ihnen das.
Ja, das kostet ihn, dass er natürlich hintenrum durchaus Zugeständnisse auch dafür machen muss, dass sie diese Zugeständnisse machen,
So war das ja bei den äh Ankündigungen, die bisher da waren auch, so ich meine, er hat sich da groß gebrüstelt mit, dass irgendwelche Unternehmen jetzt auf seinen Druck hin äh äh eine eine Änderung der Planung vorgenommen haben. Das war aber
allermeisten Fällen, entweder gab's diese Bestrebungen, das zurückzunehmen ohnehin schon.
Beziehungsweise was dann halt nicht gesagt wird das ist eben hintenrum Ulm auch Förderzusagen gab, das sieht sozusagen wieder irgendwas billiger bekommen, Steuernachlässe bekommen et cetera. Also das ist ja,
ist ja nie jetzt nicht so, dass jetzt alle nur noch äh einbrechen und sagen, oh ja, so machen wir das,
sondern die sagen, ne okay, alles klar, wenn wenn es das, was ihr hören wollt, sowas äh was könnt ihr uns dafür geben, dass wir das jetzt auch wirklich tun? Also kostenlos äh äh ist der Spaß natürlich nicht.
Also das wird nochmal ganz lustig, wie viel äh Kohleer da verbraten kann. Und ich denke, er überschätzt auch die Situation, weil er im Prinzip schaut er quasi auf die Welt mit seinem Selbstverständnis
äh des der USA in den in den in den Siebzigern und vielleicht noch in den Achtzigerjahren,
wo einfach die USA der Wirtschaftsraum schlechthin war und wo sozusagen niemand nimmt einer Form am Welthandel teilnehmen konnte, weil Welthandel war halt einfach Handel mit den USA.
Kleinen Ausnahmen, aber es ist sozusagen äh äh die Überlegenheit und die Dominanz der US-amerikanischen Wirtschaft, die war einfach enorm.
Die Situation ist nicht mehr so, ja? Sicherlich ist China noch nicht da, ähm wo die USA ist. So,
Aber sie sind bei Leibe deutlich schneller unterwegs äh dahin zu kommen als irgendjemand anderes. Zumal eben auch vollkommen neue Wirtschaftsräume entstanden sind,
Wie zum Beispiel der pazifische Raum, ja?
In dem sich nicht nur irgendwie so ein paar Boote rumtummeln, die ausm äh aus dem Einholz äh Einbaum geschlagen sind, sondern wo mittlerweile einfach die Luzie abgeht und mal so ganz nebenbei auch neunzig Prozent aller Konsumgürte dieser Welt im Kern produziert werden,
Das ist die Realität und natürlich werden sich um diese Produktionsorte herum mittelfristig äh und langfristig auch neue äh Konsumzentren bieten und kannst heutzutage in China einen bestimmten Produktbereichen,
siehe zum Beispiel Telefone sehr viel mehr Geld verdienen heute schon als in.
In den USA zum Beispiel. Sprich, wenn man sich selber abhängt und sagt, okay, wir nutzen jetzt mal hier unsere vermeintlich,
besser gestellte Situation aus, um euch unsere Bedingungen aufzudrücken, dann geht das halt in dem Moment nach hinten los, wo,
Der Anreiz dann vielleicht gar nicht so groß ist und die Leute dann sagen oh ist eigentlich so teuer ist das bei euch, ne? Ähm,
Lassen wir es einfach mal raus. Da könnt ihr ja mal sehen, wo ihr jetzt eure Konsumwaren herbekommt und dann wird's halt haarig, weil dann wird's halt auch teuer für die Amerikaner.
Das ist richtig? Nun das, genau das meine ich aber mit, dass du so ein professionell Protektionismus, den kannst du aber ein paar Jahre lang machen.
Ja, ein paar Jahre hau.
Weil ähm also ich frage mich ernsthaft, ob der mit dem Ding ähm.
Mittelfristig ähm auf die also der wird also der wird mit dem Ding nicht innerhalb von vier Jahren auf die Fresse fallen.
Das ist genau das, was ich gerade am ehesten noch als Sorge habe. Dass der äh also dieses Spiel ist ja eben ein Welter, ne? Das so Weltwirtschaft ist ein langes Spiel. Das kann er jetzt locker mal vier Jahre durchziehen.
Da werden hinter den Türen ein paar ähm äh ein paar ernste Gespräche geführt werden. Da wird ja hinter den Türen ein paar Zugeständnisse machen. Wahrscheinlich auch zu krasse Zugeständnisse, was Steuererleichterung und so weiter angeht. Und ähm,
Er muss aber eigentlich nur nach vier Jahren sagen, hier äh die Jobs sind hochgegangen.
Und.
Und dann sichert er den sich die die dann sichert er sich die nächsten vier. Auf die Fresse fließt er mit sowas nach zehn, zwölf Jahren. Wäre jetzt meine vorsichtige Schätzung.
Tja.
Aber
Ist es nicht dock, wo Weltwirtschaft will, wir schauen uns das an, wir gucken mal diese Protektionismusgeschichte. Ich glaube, äh dass er deshalb, also meine Sorge ist, dass er damit ein paar Jahre lang
innenpolitisch sich zum Held machen kann und das ist das Einzige, was er braucht, um nochmal wieder gewählt zu werden.
Ähm jetzt haben wir aber eigentlich den das Highlight des Wochenendes natürlich auch vollkommen außen vor gelassen. Das ist nämlich riesige, riesige Proteste dagegen gab. Gegen Donald Trump. Riesig. Der Woman Smarch.
Ähm der in Washington und in vielen anderen Städten in den USA,
einen Tag nachher äh abgefeiert wurde,
Und ähm der irgendwie mit mit einer Million Menschen in Washington DC und ungefähr fünf Millionen Menschen weltweit äh in die Geschichte eingeht.
Und das ist echt krass.
Ja also besser besser jetzt als nie. Wenn auch halt äh zu spät in gewisser Hinsicht.
Ähm.
Kann ich nicht einschätzen, was das in den USA mittel und langfristig für Folgen haben wird. Ob es überhaupt Folgen haben wird oder ob man sich jetzt nicht schon wieder äh,
zurücklehnt und sagt, ach guck mal, wie geil wer jetzt protestiert haben, das war doch super.
Also am Ende muss sich daraus halt eine Bewegung äh formieren. Ich meine, die Vorlage war ja hier tatsächlich eben, die von dir vorhin schon erwähnte Ready da von Martin Luca King,
und äh das Ganze war natürlich jetzt hier im Prinzip nur aufgehangen am Thema Frauen und ich denke, dass die Frauen, die das initiiert haben und ähm,
diese ganze Geschichte organisiert haben, sich auch selber nicht,
hätten vorstellen können, A, wie viel Zuspruch erstmal genau für dieses Anliegen gab, ja und B ähm wie viel.
Protest, Sabbelprotest sich gegen Trump an sich, damit ja sozusagen zusammenfindet. Also das war ja quasi ein Prote
auf mehreren Ebenen und eben hier ging's bei Laibe nicht mehr nur um Frauen, sondern hier ging's vor allem um Mann, nämlich um Trump und
Ja, da hat sich dann äh die USA von ihrer aufgeklärten und weltoffenen Seite gezeigt, die aber halt jetzt einfach mal komplett,
machtlos ist, ne? All das muss man ja auch mal sehen. Wir haben ja nicht nur Trump als Präsidenten, sondern wir haben,
Die Republikaner als unterstützende Organisation hinter ihm auf allen nennenswerten,
politischen Entscheidungsebenen in der Mehrheit. Sena.
Bald auch wieder eine Wahl, ne.
Im Kongress. Ja, aber so sieht's das halt aus. Mehrheit äh aller Gouverneure. Also es ist sozusagen schlechter, könnte es nicht sein,
Kommentar, die ich gesehen habe, war es
Das ist ja super, weil now it's now excuses, ja? Also ab jetzt ist klar, was auch immer für Scheiße passiert, wer schuld ist
Ob das dann aber am Ende durch dieses Mediengewitter äh über das wir jetzt schon so ausführlich geredet haben, noch irgendwie durchkommt, das steht natürlich auf einem ganz anderen Blatt.
Also wichtig bei so einer äh wenn, wenn es so eine von fundamentale, riesige Protestbewegung gibt, ist natürlich klar, die muss jetzt irgendwie auch weiter liefern und da werden jetzt eine Menge Leute äh bemüht sein, das äh hinzukriegen,
und die haben natürlich jetzt auch so ein bisschen das Problem, dass es hoffentlich die richtigen Leute sind. Und da werden halt auch ein paar,
ich sage mal, vielleicht ungeeignete Kandidaten dabei sein. Da werden auch Leute bei sein, die jetzt kein anderes Ziel haben, als diese Protestbewegungen zu zersetzen. Und äh gerade so spontan riesige
äh äh Protestbewegungen haben natürlich fallen dann auch in so eine Art,
Sinn und Machtvakuum. Äh dessen sich natürlich viele bemächtigen wollen und dann ist es häufig ein leichtes, die innerhalb,
Kürzerer Zeit ähm halt einfach zu blamieren, ne? Und äh durchzureichen.
So eine Montagsveranstaltung draus zu machen. Zum Beispiel.
Wichtig ist aber äh die Onjan, ein Satireblatt äh schrieb dann äh Mike Pence enttäuscht,
von den zweihunderttausend Ehemännern und Vätern, die Frauen erlaubt haben an diesem Protest teilzunehmen. Das fand ich eine sehr schöne.
Aber.
Es hat zumindest mich so ein bisschen, wir haben an dem wir haben mit dem amerikanischen Freund am am am am Abend des zwanzigsten quasi ähm,
Bewältigung gemacht, ne? Gesprächs- und Trinktherapie und ähm am am
Am einundzwanzigsten diese massiven Protest oder diese in ihrer in ihrem Ausmaß so riesigen Proteste zu sehen, äh hat zumindest für mich so halbwegs so nochmal so ein bisschen,
Frieden mit den USA Bewohnern. Äh fließen lassen.
Ja klar. Also ich meine, das ist äh in den USA jetzt nicht alles nur wahnsinnige sind, ist äh vollkommen klar, dass das hier im Prinzip auch eine Minderheit übernommen hat, ist auch klar.
Aber das ist halt auch leider die Erkenntnis, dass eine Minderheit eben auch ausreicht und am Ende äh mit den erworbenen Machtinstrumenten eben die Mehrheit äh so verstört, dass dass sie dann eben auch mitzieht.
Diese ganzen Hitlervergleiche, das ist in gewisser Hinsicht ermüdend, aber da kann man sich schon so einiges abgucken.
Da wurde sich auch schon so einiges abgeguck.
Eine Überleitung wie im Bilder, wo hast du das jetzt absichtlich gemacht oder aus Versehen? Ja, lichter lächelt der Tim nur gewiss.
Bist du einfach Profi.
Björn Höcke.
Irgendwie Vorsitzender der thüringischen Alternative für Deutschland? Hm, hat in Dresden.
Eine Rede gehalten vor äh der jungen Alternative, das ist deren also die Höcke Jugend quasi, ne, die die äh eine Jugendorganisation.
Organisation. Oh ja.
Und ähm hat ja irgendwie eine einen riesigen Zinova äh Veranstalter. Also die Rede muss man sich echt mal anhören. Das ist.
Das Spannende an dieser Rede ist, deswegen erwähne ich die hier überhaupt. Die behandelt einfach mal so gut wie kein nennenswertes Problem.
Dass äh Deutschland gerade unbedingt hätte. Ne, das ist eine reine Hetzrede und richtig irgendwie darüber auf, dass wir.
Mahnmal für die ermordeten Juden Europas haben. Regt sich auf, dass äh ähm.
Das Deutsche irgendwie hält wieder stolz sein müssen oder sowas, ne? Und ich meine, das ist nun wirklich eines der geringsten Probleme, denen die Bundesrepublik Deutschland gerade gegenüber steht, ist seit wir seit gut fünfzehn Jahren hm ein.
Weltweit beachtetes Denkmal haben.
Geschweige denn, dass die Deutschen nicht äh stolz genug werden Deutsch zu sein, ne? Also da haben sie ja äh es ist einfach nicht ähm,
das Problem,
Und ähm deswegen finde ich das sehr spannend, sich diese diese Rede tatsächlich einmal ähm anzuschauen, wie Sascha Lore das auch äh empfiehlt in seiner Kolumne.
Bei Spiegel online.
Und einfach mal darauf zu achten, welche Anleihen denn nimmt.
Und was das für ein Unsinn ist, ja? Ich weiß auf einen langen, entbehrungsreichen Weg und da ist es so, also da da hast du irgendwie, ich meine, fällt dir noch was ein zu dieser Rede.
Na ja
mein das Ganze steht einfach im Kontext des der AfD Beschlusses, wie man den jetzt in der in diesem Jahr vorzugehen hat
mit äh gezielten Provokationen, Öffentlichkeit zu schaffen.
So und das machen sie halt in äh alle Extreme hinein und offensichtlich ist es in in Sachsen und in Thüringen mittlerweile so weit, dass man da einfach nur noch äh äh
eine Steigerung erzielen kann, wenn man quasi offen voll äh in die Nazi
Ruhe greift und einfach mal den selben Scheiß da nochmal wieder runterbetet. Ich meine, dieses ganze Copy-Pasting hast du ja auch bei Trump gesehen irgendwie, du hast ja noch gar nicht diesen Kuchen erwähnt.
Nordkuchen.
Ja, the cake is a li.
Ja, das das ist ja dann immer nur, also das ist ja.
Ja so und äh so machen sie das halt auch. Ich meine, die geben sich jetzt nicht besonders viel Mühe. Da wird halt einfach nur noch äh rausgehauen, was geht, weil sie halt auch die Grenzen testen wollen. Weil sie auch überhaupt gar keine Angst haben.
Noch irgendwas zu überschreiten. Ich meine man hat's ja jetzt gesehen. So, jetzt haben sie sich immer mit dem Körper zusammengehalten und dann so, ha, nee, also rausschmeißen können wir den jetzt aber nicht.
Ja, das ist also was was es ist im Prinzip immer das Gleiche, ne? Schick mal einen vor, der soll mal da rumtrampeln, damit wird der ähm.
Wird der ein paar Leute vollends überzeugen und für den Rest der Leute ähm machen wir dann einen Tag später irgendwie eine Richterstellung und sagen, wir wurden falsch verstanden oder so, ne? Hat ja auch.
Gar nicht gemeint.
So war das gar nicht gemeint, ne? Ja, der Satz ist jetzt zum Beispiel, wir Deutschen, also unser Volk sind das einzige Volk der Welt, das sich ein Denkmal der Schande in das Herz seiner Hauptstadt gepflanzt hat. Ähm,
Und irgendwie später war dann ein Gegner so Debatte los, ja, dass Rudolf Augstein das auch einmal so genannt hat, ne? Ähm,
Aber der, der hat gesagt, dass wir uns der Schande ein Denkmal setzen, ja? Also ein und dann dann muss das jetzt irgendwie die muss das jetzt irgendwie Deutschlehrer äh bemühen äh die erklären, ob das jetzt ein Denkmal der Schande ist.
Oder ähm.
Eine Schande des Denkmals, ja? Und und irgendwie solche Debatten, aber genau solche wollen die natürlich provozieren durch so eine Rede. Diese Rede war nicht äh aus einer Bierlaune herausgehalten. Die ist genau,
so formuliert, wie sie formuliert sein sollte, dass man in den entscheidenden Zitaten die sich am Ende dann die Journalisten rauspicken und sagen, hier, ja.
Ähm tatsächlich am einzelnen Zitat noch rülen kann,
wo dann auch irgendwie irgendwie Leute hingehen und sagen, ja äh ähm Unmiss äh hat er sich missverständlich ausgedruckt, das hat er bestimmt nicht so gemeint, ne? Also allein auf die, genau auf diese Reaktion ist diese Rede ja auch ausgelegt gewesen. Dass du am Ende
im im Gesamtkontext, guckst dir das Ding an
und das einfach eine hast du einfach eine ganz klar ist ganz klar wovon er redet, welchen Spirit der da äh vermitteln möchte und wie die Leute drauf sind, die sich das anhören
Ähm aber wenn das dann so gedruckt in der Zeitung ist, ne und der liberale
ähm äh Geisteswissenschaftler liest das dann, dann denkt er sich, na ja aber,
Duden, was er hier eigentlich sagt ist, ne? Oder eine Katze an jedem einzelnen Satz kannst du dann wieder was feilen, ne? Kannst dann irgendwie überlegen, ob wie das äh vielleicht doch nicht so gemeint war und dann hast du quasi die Möglichkeit, vor denen, die.
Vor den spitzfindigen die in irgend so eine wie war das jetzt gemeint Debatte äh zu äh zu verzählen, ja,
dann denken wieder und hast dann für den größeren Teil der Gesellschaft die nicht hören wollen, ne? Die nämlich gerade mit der AfD sympathisieren.
Und aber nur nicht an dem Punkt sind, dass sie sagen, ja klar, äh ich bin voll der Nazi, so, ne? Sondern an dem Punkt sind, dass sie so sagen, Mensch, war doch schön hier, ähm.
Fußball-WM und,
Fußball EM, ne? Da konnten wir doch mal Hammer mal wieder einen positiven Umgang mit der Fahne geübt. Ähm, da konnten wir zusammen feiern, ne? Da haben wir uns gefreut. Dat Verdo ist doch gar nicht so verkehrt. Ähm.
Wenn wir damit auch weitermachen können mit einem positiven ähm Nationalgefühl, ne? Ist ja eine These, die man vertreten kann. Ähm.
Und wenn dann und dann denkst du AfD, ja, die machen noch hier was, ne? Und dann mit den mit den Flüchtlingen, das ja vielleicht auch tatsächlich nicht so positiv gelaufen oder da hätte man, kann man, ne, da könnte man, hätten da einige Sachen besser gehen können.
Ähm da sympathisiere ich mit. Weil die mir im Prinzip ein positives Gefühl,
Für mich selber und für Deutschland geben,
Und gegen die Eliten und gegen äh die Fremden, die uns hier so, ne? Die möchte auch erstmal irgendwie Germany first haben. Hm?
Und denen die die wären eigentlich noch Kandidaten eigentlich angewiedert zu sein von so einer Rede.
Und zu sagen, na ja okay, hör mal, so hatte ich mir das auch nicht vorgestellt, ne? Also so irgendwie Vollnazi äh muss vielleicht jetzt auch nicht sein. Das ist auf jeden Fall das äh die entscheidende Wählerschaft für die AfD
ne? Die können ein paar Extremisten ähm mobilisieren, damit kommen die auch wahrscheinlich über fünf Prozent, ja?
Also mit reine Flatout, Nazi-Scheiße, ja? Aber so um irgendwie über zwanzig zu kommen, müssen die noch irgendwo so ein bisschen mehr Finesse zeigen.
Und die entfalten sie genau in diesen äh ja das war aber nicht so gemeint, Debatten und dann äh ne, dann wird man irgendwie einen Tag debattiert, ob der äh AfD-Vorstand jetzt einen, dass er ein Ausschluss Höckes debattiert wird.
Ne und dann,
dann ist das Feuer aber auch irgendwie wieder vorbei und dann wird irgendwie gesagt, ja ne der kriegt jetzt schwere Ordnungsmaßnahmen oder sowas, ne, lassen wir schon bei uns sein. Äh,
lange genug, um um die die neuen Umfrageergebnisse zu bekommen und zu sehen, war das jetzt äh Netto ähm plus oder Minus, was dafür passiert ist, stellt sich raus, hat funktioniert,
ne?
Und ab jetzt und damit gleichzeitig natürlich auch die Grenzen wieder auszuloten für ähm das, was man bei der nächsten Rede sagt, ne? Der wird natürlich weitermachen. Du brauchst einfach einen, der am Rande da rumprovoziert, ne? Äh und im Prinzip den Diskursrahmen,
so ein bisschen erweitert, damit du nämlich am Ende,
dich mit der, mit der Partei, die da gewählt ist und den Leuten, die diese Partei führen, so halbwegs noch in so einer Art Mitte fühlst, ja? Dass du nämlich natürlich nicht den Extremisten der Partei gewählt hast,
sondern die moderaten Kräfte.
Ne, die sagen, die dann auch mal so jemanden zur Ruhe rufen, ne? Ist ein Spiel, was die was die CDU seit Jahrzehnten sehr erfolgreich spielt, ne? Die sich irgendwie äh so ein paar Extremisten am Rande hält
Gut jetzt dummerweise eine ihrer schärfsten Extremistinnen ist jetzt ausgetreten und geht wahrscheinlich zur AfD rüber, ja? Ist natürlich doof.
Aber es ist sehr entscheidend, äh bei sowas halt eine Metaperspektive zu behalten und sich nicht in drei Tage Free Ton Debatte darüber einzulassen.
Ob der Wiedersatz grammatikalisch korrekt zu interpretieren ist. Du musst dir nur diesen diesen Typen fünf Minuten die Räder anhalten anschauen.
Und gucken wie die Leute darauf abgehen um zu sehen was da los ist. Und wenn du auf einmal, also was ja auch häufig Leute sagen, ne, so, ja, habe ich ja welche, also,
dass ich irgendwie diese ganzen Nazis und Verschwörungstheoretiker im Schlepptau habe, das ist doch nicht meine Schuld.
Das bin ich doch nicht schuld, ne? Also, wenn die das jetzt hier falsch verstehen, das ist natürlich ärgerlich, aber das ist ja, da ich da trage ich doch keine Verantwortung dran, ne,
ja, wende dir dir, wenn du dir einmal mobilisierst nicht.
Aber wenn die, wenn die einen größeren Teil dein deiner Fans ausmachen, äh musst du dir einmal kurz Gedanken darüber machen, was für Gedankengute du da vorantreibst. Da kannst du jedes Mal noch mit deiner, mit deiner Grammatikalischen Schwitzfindigkeit kommen,
Die grammatikalische Spitzfindigkeit hat den größeren Teil der Leute da draußen nie interessiert. Die haben von vorne herein verstanden, worum es geht und die hören auch nicht mit dem Duden.
Sondern die hören mit ihrem Herzen.
Tja, ich freue mich immer, ob man sozusagen jetzt als Gegenmaßnahme einfach mal genauso explizit werden sollte und wie man das dann am besten tut,
Ich meine, wenn sozusagen die Übertreibung und die alternativen Fakten äh äh jetzt dominant sind so, dann könnte man sich ja mal überlegen, dass jetzt eine.
Bemerkung äh noch nicht unbedingt ein Vorschlag ob man nicht den Spieß äh.
Auch umdrehen kann. Und ob man ihn umdrehen sollte. Bin ich mir jetzt nicht so sicher.
Weil man will ja dann sozusagen auch, ne? Die Würde,
aller Menschen auch bewahren. Das ist also ein bisschen so ein Problem ist, ne? Dass man jetzt nicht.
Mal sicher nicht gleich wie ein Unmensch benehmen will, nur weil äh Unmenschen am Horizont sind, ne. Das ist natürlich auch so eine interessante Debatte, mit darf man jetzt irgendwie Nazis äh einer äh eine knallen oder nicht. Da gab's ja dieses lustige äh Video mit diesem Spencer. Wie heißt er noch.
Spencer, das war kein, das hat keinen Knall bekommen, das war ein Ort high five.
Ja, genau.
Nein, also ist ja, ich, die Debatte wollte ich natürlich gerade äh so ein bisschen umschiffen, weil ich weiß, wie die sich dann wieder in den Kommentaren entfaltet. Was passiert ist, ist dieser Richard Spencer ist, das ist der Typ, den haben wir ja auch schon mal, auf den haben wir schon mal Bezug genommen.
Der mit dem Heil, Tram.
Heil Tramp, äh, dessen Zuhörerschaft dann da irgendwie Hitlergröße groß gemacht hat, ne? Und der einfach auch ganz klar einfach ein, also er bezeichnet sich selbst als weißer Nationalist
ne? Ja, also sagt, okay, wir haben eine weiße Kultur und diese.
Ne
Nee, Supremacy äh sagte umsifft er
Also er sagt tatsächlich, ich will mir mal ein längeres Interview mit ihm angehört. Er sagt also er ist kein Surpremisist, weil Supremacy heißt ja, dass die Weißen grundsätzlich besser sind
Äh er erkennt aber an, dass in in einigen Teilen die Asiaten sogar noch besser sind als die Weißen. Und er will aber einfach nur für die, für die Interessen der der weißen Identität,
äh einstehen, ne? Wir weißen Rasse äh Rassenidentität. Ähm klar, das ist äh
das ist genauso eine Spitzfindigkeit. Der Typ ist einfach ein fremdenfeindlicher Nazi,
und im Rahmen dieser äh dieser Women's March Geschichten war das glaube ich oder also im Rahmen der der ich weiß nicht genau ob das am zwanzigsten äh am neunzehnten oder am
äh am zwanzigsten oder am einundzwanzigsten war, äh war da irgendwie in in einer äh mit einem.
Fernsehinterview beschäftigt und erklärte gerade mal wieder, dass er äh dass er eben einen derer weißer Nationalist ist.
Als wenn einfach jemand äh kam und ihm kurzerhand einen auf die Fresse gehauen hat,
Ein Schlag, der hat gesessen äh Thema erledigt Message gegeben. Die Person ist halt gegangen. Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, also das Internet äh äh blühte auf in Entzücken,
Tausende verschiedene Gifts davon mit aller möglichen musikalischen Untermalungen und feierten jetzt dass dieser Typ einen auf die Nase bekommen hat,
Was natürlich muss man einfach mal sagen. Ähm auch ne unschöne Blüte ist,
wenn äh so eine Gewalthäme und Verherrlichung im im Netz stattfindet. So, das ist jetzt ist auch nicht unbedingt etwas, woran ich mich entzücken würde.
Andererseits war das natürlich schon auch relativ witzig. Und ähm jetzt musst du irgendwie, ähm, muss man irgendwie seinen Umgang damit finden, ne? Ist eine Debatte, die man die gerade natürlich auch wieder äh herzlich geführt wird, ne? Ist es okay, einen Nazi zu schlagen oder nicht?
Ist es okay, das zu feiern oder nicht. Der hat der schon mal jemanden geschlagen, ne? Äh wie wägen wir das auf? Aber es sind auch wieder so Debatten. Ich würde diesen Schlag einfach mal als äh auch als Zeichen der Hilflosigkeit werten
die wir nicht nur in den USA äh sondern auch in Deutschland. Natürlich haben im Umgang mit solchen Leuten.
Es ist der großen Mehrheit klar, dass das die Falschen sind, um ihnen politische Macht zu geben,
die sind inkompetent, die schüren Hass.
Die leben von Hass, die wollen Hass, die wollen uns entzweien, ja? Uns als Menschheit, uns als, als eine politische, als ein politischer Körper, als eine politische Bewegung, die,
wollen andere benachteiligen.
Und das ist auf jeden Fall nicht eine Politik der eine positive Zukunftsvision inne ist.
Und ähm Sascha Lobos äh in dem Text, den ich gerade schon zitiert habe, der wirklich wichtig ist, den wir unbedingt gelesen haben sollte. Sagt ein Gedankenherxperiment. Wenn sich einhundert Menschen versammeln und ein paar sind darunter, die Murmelnazi-Zeug,
Das macht die restlichen fünfundneunzig Prozent nicht zu Nazis. Aber wenn diese Part zum Beispiel anfangen würden, sichtbar Harkenkreuzfahrten zu hissen.
Dann kommt ein essentieller Moment. Wie gehen die fünfundneunzig Prozent mit den Fünfen um? Akzeptiert die große Mehrheit diese Symbole unwidersprochen.
Bleiben die fünf ein Teil der Gruppe,
Ab einem bestimmten Punkt steht die gehisste Fahne nicht mehr nur für die fünf, sondern kann oder muss als Absichtserklärung der gesamten Gruppe verstanden werden.
So funktioniert politische Gruppendynamik, über Zustimmung, Schweigen und Abgrenzung. Und es gibt einen Moment, da wird schweigen zur Zustimmung, als würde man ohne Protest einer Fahne.
Hinterherlaufen. Und das ist genau das, was gerade in Deutschland auch stattfindet.
Wann ist der Moment erreicht, wo man entweder die Unterstützung eben vollständig entziehen muss.
Oder wo man Stillschwein noch mitmacht. Und wann ist der Punkt erreicht? Und das ist der lange Bogen dieser Sendung, wo man sich irgendwann nicht mehr erlauben kann, dem entgegenzutreten.
Stellung zu beziehen.
Und noch haben wir die Gelegenheit dazu, um das mit mit öffentlichen Äußerungen zu machen.
Noch haben wir die Gelegenheit dazu ähm das als politische Bewegung zu machen.
Und was dieser Trump-Sprecher-Presser äh Pressesprecher Presse Pressebrecher? Presse, was habe ich jetzt gesagt,
Pressepresser, ne? Der presst die Presse.
Presse. Presse. Pressebrecher.
Pressebrecher und Pressepresser. Ähm was der ähm gerade macht ist zu zeigen, dass der Moment jetzt langsam mal vorbei ist.
Und der, dass es ab jetzt anders läuft.
Und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage und ich glaube nach, dass es der einzige Maßstab, nachdem so ein Schlag am Ende zu bewerten ist.
Führt der dazu, ähm dass den weniger Leute, die diesen Spencer zusprechen oder führt ja dazu, dass dem mehr zusprechen.
Das ist eigentlich alles, wonach ich sowas bewerten würde.
Ja und was denkst du.
Schwierig, ich habe im Moment den Eindruck, dass das ähm zu einer, dass die ähm die.
Allright. Ähm es relativ gut hinkriegen diese dies als ein Akt äh der barbarischen und Gewalt,
und der Diskursunfähigkeit,
darzustellen. Das ist das, was immer passiert, wenn du äh wenn du mit Gewalt vorgehst, ne.
Es sei denn, du, du bist Nazi, dann ist das natürlich ein bedauerliches Missverständnis. Sprengstoffsammler, hm oder so, ne?
Aber man kann solche Handlungen nicht mehr äh getrennt von ihrer öffentlichen Wirkung in der Breite vollführen.
Ja, es ist halt auch nicht äh jedem gegeben
in einer angemessenen intellektuellen äh Ebene sich damit auseinanderzusetzen, ja? Also erstmal, wenn man die direktuelle Gabel so selber auch nicht hat oder andere Ängste da vielleicht auch noch eine Rolle mitspielen,
sorry, sollte ich eben geben irgendwie gleich äh in Gewalt äh zu übergehen?
Interessant, vielleicht in dem Zusammenhang ähm ein Mitschnitt aus dem US-Fernsehen von,
ähm Moderator, der heißt Roland Martin, der mit diesem Richard Spencer ein Interview führt. Hast du da auch gesehen.
Ja, ja, den wollte ich, ich habe das gerade nochmal parallel gegoogelt und wollte erst grade äh.
Ähm wo er wirklich dieses,
durchaus zu bevorzugende, wenn auch schwer zu erzielende Moment von, ich nehme dich jetzt einfach mal komplett auseinander und alle deine Argumente, die du jetzt hier irgendwie nennst, äh ja, wenn ich wenn ich die sozusagen auseinander nehme, dann dann merkt man auch, wie lächerlich das ist.
Der hat den echt gegrillt.
Er hat den wirklich gegrillt und es war in gewisser Hinsicht dann äh auch sehr viel produktiver. Das wie es schon gesagt kann, kann natürlich jetzt nicht jeder äh leisten. Es muss so ist.
Also der hat dem, der hat ihm viel übler einen auf die Fresse gegeben. Eine richtig Übel hat der dem aufgefressen. Der lag am Boden, hat er noch reingetreten.
Aber grandios gemacht, ne? Und das ich muss aber die ganze Zeit auch grinsen mit diesem Höcke, da ist mir vorhin, da ist wieder eingefallen,
Es gibt so aus den,
Aus den Uhrzeiten der deutschen Wikipedia, also als das so losging und als diese Seele noch cool war, gab's,
Verschiedene Projekte, aber vor allem eins, das haben wir auch seinerzeit mal in der Chaosreiseaussendung erwähnt, die Camilleopedia, ne, die so ein bisschen so eine,
Weißt du, so von der alternative, lustige äh Sicht auf die Welt bietet aus der Perspektive von Kamelen.
Und ähm,
Da kann man dann halt auch große deutsche äh Diktatoren nachschlagen. Allerdings ist halt alles irgendwie so ein bisschen in diesem Kamel, Style, auch alles ein bisschen unbenannt und und wie ist unser großer äh äh Führer dort gedannt? Ach,
Adolf Höckler.
Ja, also Adolf Höckler. Äh auf allen Gebieten talentfrei
Ob Postkartenmaler und Erfolgslöser, Hobbystratege, lebenslanger Identitätskrise. Erlitter Zwangsvorstellung
die er vehement verteidigte, dass Kamele ausschließlich braun und kurzhöckig zu sein haben
Höckler ginge die Geschichte ein, als ein ungescheites Seitengescheidetes Obernazi-Kamel mit einem selbst für ein Kamir sehr großen Maul und einem sehr kleinen Bart, der nach seinem Tode eigenständig weiterlebte
Fand ich schon immer sehr lustig.
Also er hat klar. Sie sind offiziell entlarvt und.
Man kann ihm jetzt nur mal so ein schönes Gespräch. Man kann ihm nur äh ein äh ein Gespräch mit Roll and Martin wünschen.
Ja, genau. Da wird auch noch in Deutschland wird sich auch noch so ein Robin Martin äh finden. Daran mangelt es allerding.
Glaube, ja, ich glaube, dass das am Ende der äh Böhmermann wird.
Ja, mal gucken, ob er sich ihm stellt.
Ja
So jetzt Schluss mit Trump.
Schluss mit Trump und Schlüssel mit Höcke äh machen wir weiter mit Social Whats und Fake News. Wir müssen mal ganz kurz der Chronisten fliegen. Nächste, diese Woche, diese Woche ist ein Fachgespräch im
im Deutschen Bundestag zu Social Bots, da gibt's irgendwie eine Studie, die jetzt äh veröffentlicht wurde, in ein Thesenpapier zum öffentlichen Fachgespräch,
Äh das haben wir dann schon mal in den Shownotes und äh ich berichte dann nächste Woche, weil ich auch zu diesem Fachgespräch eingeladen bin.
Und ähm dann würde ich trotzdem noch ganz kurz darauf eingehen wollen, dass ähm die Union jetzt ähm.
Facebook zur Richtigstellung von Fake News verpflichten will. Also du kriegst dann so eine Gegendarstellung.
Weil die Tracken ja eh was du gesehen hast und geklickt hast und was nicht und dann kommst du nächste Mal, kommst du nächstes Mal, machst du Facebook, ne? Neuer Login und da musst du dich erstmal durch die ganzen Gegendarstellungen klicken, was da alles für eine Scheiße gelesen hast.
Das könnte lustig werden.
Das könnte noch der Gamechanger sein, weil das denn irgendwann äh dann kriegst du den den Gegendarstellungsblocker äh Plugin in mir für deinen Browser. Das ist äh das ist echt noch ähm das wird noch ganz amüsant.
Ähm und dann empfehle ich noch
ein ein etwas längeren von Craps, Bryan Craps, der Typ der vor ein paar Monaten
dessen Blog ähm Craps on Security
das erste prominente Opfer des des großen Mirai Bottnetz wurde, ja, wo also der, dessen Seite ja dann platt war und dann konnten,
muss der AKA mal irgendwann sagen, sorry, wir kriegen das auch nicht mehr hin, äh was hier an an Gigabits reinfliegt und dann sagt der Google, na gut, dann horsten wir dich
der also bis dato die größte Dedos-Attacke, der der äh der Geschichte des Internets abbekommen hat.
Ähm der hat sich dann gedacht, okay, wer hat denn eigentlich dieses Mira Bodnet da äh äh verbrochen und hat dann da hinterher recherchiert? Und hat mehrere Monate sich da reingekniet
und hat äh herausgefunden, wer der Autor zu sein scheint von diesem Mira Award net. Und welche Strukturen sich dahinter befinden.
Und es war wenig schwer zu erwarten war am Ende der Gründer und Inhaber einer dedosmetiges Firma ähm aber das,
es ist.
Jetzt schon belegt oder erstmal nur so eine Behauptung.
Na ja, also ich meine, wenn das nicht belegt ist, dann wird der äh für den Artikel bald in Grund und Boden geklagt werden.
Aber es ist wirklich ein relativ ziemlich lange äh ziemlich lange äh äh Geschichte,
ganz vielen verschiedenen Personen, aber zentral ist eben dieser Parastar, äh der ähm,
eine Frühmal namens Pro-Traffs Solutions ähm gegründet hat und äh das also ist einfach spannend, das mal zu lesen, wie der sich da reingekniet hat. Äh könnte echt, wäre das ähm.
Wenn das so äh alles Bestand hat und ich glaube, er hätte das nicht publiziert, wenn er sich da nicht sicher wäre, dann wäre das echt nochmal ähm.
Ein schöner Punkt.
Aber ich meine, das ist ja eine interessante Parallele zu den äh.
Ich kann ja jetzt keinen Fall nennen, aber das ist ja sozusagen auch äh sagen wir mal so, zu mir so ein Thema, auch in diesem äh Viren, Antivirus, Komplex,
Ja, also wer profitiert am meisten von Angriffen, ja. Diejenigen, die die Angriffe vorgeben zu verteidigen, so, ja.
Was nicht, ob man da jetzt irgendeinen Fall nennen kann, ob dir da irgendwas einfällt. Ich bin da jetzt gerade etwas Geschichtssprache, ich beschreib's einfach mal ganz allgemein. Das war natürlich hier einfach mal.
Ein ein Korruptionsmuster äh vorfindest, wo.
Quasi Firmen den Bedarf für ihre eigenen Firma ähm dadurch schaffen, indem sie diese Tatbestände auch gleich mitschaffen.
Ja, der also diese äh.
Diese Überlegung jetzt natürlich bei den Serviceangriffen im professionellen Bereich schon länger, ne? Ähm.
Das ganze Modell einer äh Dinal of Service Angriffs ist ja das Geschäftsmodell, wenn man den denn als Erpresser macht, ist ja, dass man danach einen die Dienstleistung anbietet, dass das aufhört,
und ähm natürlich kann man das äh in diesem Bereich der äh der ähm der Erpressung machen,
Oder man kann halt ein renommierter Dedos äh Metigator werden und äh wo Kunden sucht man sich halt dadurch, dass man einfach regelmäßig mal irgendwo äh was runternimmt, was ein potenzieller Kunde sein könnte, ne. Ähm.
Wie gesagt, der Text ist lang und wir haben eine lange Sendung auch hinter uns. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein ein Interesting Read und äh deswegen sei das an dieser Stelle nochmal empfohlen.
Damit wir jetzt zumindest hier noch ein bisschen Netzpolitische Aspekte äh.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das politisch, also ein politischer Aspekt ist, ne.
Auch nicht auch nicht politisch, ne? Müssen's umbenennen. Da ist Lockbuch.
Ja, das ja, ich war ja kann man nur mal überlegen, hm.
So und damit sind wir am Ende einer Sendung angelangt, die mal wieder viel zu lang geworden ist.
Ja, geringfügig.
Ich hoffe, wir haben ein paar unserer äh unserer Perspektiven äh rüberbringen können und euch dafür begeistern können.
Das war jetzt mal so ein bisschen mehr Meter.
Ja. Das war auch gezielt Meter. Wir wollten das mal machen. Vielleicht auch um um ähm ein bisschen Groundwork zu legen, damit wir vielleicht auch mal wieder in Zukunft.
Auf Dinge verkürzt blicken können wieder und wie es uns häufig sehr gut gelingt.
Ob das jetzt was Positives oder was Negatives ist, äh überlassen wir euch.
Genau.
Wir freuen uns aber natürlich weiterhin auf den Zuspruch, den wir erfahren in äh in in irgendwie freundlichen Geschenken oder in den Spenden, die dieses Projekt ja am Leben halten,
und ähm ja und auch über sonstigen Zuspruch.
Genau und vor allem freuen wir uns mal über äh über jeden, der sich äh äh ermutigt sieht in diesem Jahr mal nicht nur sich das alles
anzuhören und äh stumm zu nicken, weil ich denke, es einfach wichtig ist, jetzt mal ins eigene Umfeld
mindestens ins eigene Umfeld, aber das auf jeden Fall mal, egal wie dieses Umfeld gestrickt sein mag,
Umso merkwürdiger es gestrickt ist, umso wichtiger ist es vielleicht. Einfach mal diese Position und diese äh Sichtweisen, die ihr hier,
nichts eins zu eins übernommen habt, aber ja sozusagen das Resultat eurer eigenen Überlegung auch mal ins Umfeld tragt und dort,
vorbringt und äh auch andere Leute dazu erbunden hat, Stellung zu beziehen und Positionen einzunehmen,
Um einfach mal klar zu machen, dass äh es sich hier nicht um eine Mehrheit handelt, die uns hier versucht zu schaden,
auch wenn sie sich gerne als solche geriert und durch Drohung und andere äh Tricks und Versuche versucht äh hier,
Dinge zu fallen zu bringen und,
Ich weiß nicht, ob das alleine schon reicht, aber es ist auf jeden Fall die Voraussetzung, überhaupt irgendwas zu bewegen.
Wie heißt es so ein bisschen die Voraussetzung für ein für ein also wenn uns.
Am politischen Diskurs irgendwie noch was gelegen ist, dann müssen wir das ähm mehr oder weniger in diesem Jahr.
In allen anderen Jahren auch, aber in dem kommenden Jahr insbesondere das Verteidigen.
Ja, wenn sie uns in diesem Jahr nicht gelingt, dann äh haben wir es in den nächsten Jahren auf jeden Fall deutlich schwerer. Und äh das fängt halt auch im Kleinen an. Ich hatte jetzt gerade vor ein paar Tagen äh,
Kneipendebatte, wo ich das einfach mal aufgebracht habe, was ich sonst vielleicht nicht getan hätte, hält sie auch raus, so steht dann so einer neben mir so, ja, ach ist das doch egal, ich halte mich da raus, ich bin nicht wähler und so.
Hast du direkt eine Fresse gehauen, ne.
Und ich habe ihm einfach gesagt, wenn man es gibt keine Nichtwähler. Ja, also wenn du wenn du nicht wählst, wenn du da nicht klar Position beziehst, dann dann bist du Teil des Problems.
Ganz einfach. Und? Nadel guckt.
Einfach auf Leute zeigen und ihnen sagen, was sie, dass sie äh nicht einfach nur rumstehen können. Hm.
Dass er das auch so so und auch so offensichtliches Nicht-Handeln halt auch ein Handeln ist und dass dass man sich dadurch eben nicht nicht rausziehen kann, dass man danach schon dann auch äh damit rechnen muss, nochmal gefragt zu werden,
Ich lese äh mit mit so einer,
Mischung aus ähm Belustigung, aber auch äh Beunruhigung, äh diesen Trump Regreats äh äh Twitter-Account und mal wieder ein Twitter-Konto zu zu empfehlen, wo die ganze Zeit halt so
Leute, die bedauern Trump gewählt haben, äh, retwittet werden. So, die jetzt einfach feststellen, so oh ivote for you, but.
Aber.
Bist irgendwie jetzt muss ich irgendwie auf einmal fünfhunderttausend Dollar im Jahr Kosten tragen, die ich mit Forderbild Care Act ja gehabt hätte. Was soll denn das, das war, so war's aber nicht gemeint. Ich dachte, du wolltest uns hier irgendwie,
Ja, du wolltest uns hier ins Licht führen, weil ihr es halt wirklich geglaubt haben oder sich nicht genug Gedanken darüber gemacht haben, so. Deswegen.
Politik ist ihr, ja, ich weiß auch gar nicht. Ich habe irgendwie, ich weiß auch gar nicht, wann ich irgendwie auf diesen doofen Trichter gekommen bin, mich irgendwie so viel für Politik zu interessieren.
Ja, weiß ich auch nicht. Mich hast du jetzt mit reingerissen.
Das war, du hast mich da mit reingerissen.
Nee, ich habe für Politik interessiert, habe ich mich vorher auch schon. Na ja.
Ja. So Leute jetzt habt ihr bis hier durchgehalten jetzt wünschen wir euch auch noch einen schönen Tag.
Genau versucht mal noch einen schönen Tag zu haben. Viel Spaß, ne? Tschö.
Tschüss.